GOOD MORNING. THE
HONORABLE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE
MEDINA. HONORABLE GUESTS LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN. EQUITY IN UPPER
ACCESS WITHIN THE EDUCATIONAL
SYSTEM. AN OUTSIDE WITHIN THE
WORLD OF WORK IS AN EXTENSION
OF OUR LONG DIFFICULT AN UGLY
HISTORY. NOW FOR TOO LONG ONLY
OFFERED LIP SERVICE TO EQUITY
AND NOW DEPRIVED MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE FROM REACHING THEIR
FULLEST POTENTIAL. AND I'VE
ALSO DEPRIVED THE NATION FROM
VITAL AND CREATIVE PRIEST IS
NOT COMES FROM ITS DIVERSE
CHILDREN. WE ARE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM HAVE
COMMITTED OURSELVES FOR THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS TO DECREASE
EQUITY BY 40% IN THE COMING
FIVE YEARS. AND TOTALLY
ELIMINATED WITHIN TEN YEARS.
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS
EXCERPTED THE PROPOSAL. IT'S
TOUGH FOR SOME ON DIVERSITY TO
INTEGRATE DIVERSITY EQUITY AND
INCLUSION INTO THE VISION OF
SUCCESS DURING ITS MEETING HELD
HERE IN RIVERSIDE. SEPTEMBER
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN. AND IT
ALSO ACCEPTED TO AUTHORIZE THE
STATE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
ADVOCATES CHANGES IN TITLE FIVE
TO ENABLE US TO DO THAT.
OBVIOUSLY SUCH FUNDAMENTAL
CHANGES WILL INEVITABLY REQUIRE
INCREASED RESOURCES. OUR
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS THESE
INTRACTABLE PROBLEM INCLUDES TO
INCREASE OUR **** OF THE
CULTURAL COMPETENCIES. TO
ENHANCE OUR COMMITMENT TO
BUILDING A CULTURE OF EQUITY
MINDEDNESS. AND TO DIVERSIFY
OUR FACULTY HIRING. IT IS
THEREFORE BE SHOOTING THAT THIS
HEARING. IS BEING CONDUCTED A
DRIVER'S SIDE CITY COLLEGE. IT
IS A RARE PRIVILEGE AND
PLEASURE FOR ME TO INTRODUCE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JOSE MAYOR. A
LIFELONG EDUCATOR A CHAMPION OF
EDUCATION AND OUR EDUCATIONAL
INSTITUTIONS. BEFORE SERVING IN
THE CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY HE WAS
A THREE TERM MEMBER OF THE
RIVERSIDE COMING TO COLLEGE
DISTRICT BOARD OF TRUSTEES. AND
A TEACHER OUT FOR THE HIGH
SCHOOL. TODAY HE IS CHAIR OF
THE ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
HIGHER EDUCATION. AND DURING
HIS TENURE AS CHAIR HE HAS
CONTINUED TO BE A STRONG
CHAMPION FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. HE'S A LEADER IN THE
FORMING THE CALDERON PROGRAM TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO QUALIFY FOR
FINANCIAL AID. AND TO BE BASED
ON TOTAL COST OF ATTENDANCE IN
THIS ONLY ON TUITION. WE ARE SO
PROUD TO HOST THE COMMITTEES
FIELD HEARING TODAY. ON FACULTY
DIVERSITY EFFORT AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. EIGHT FIVE NUMBERS
SHOW NEARLY 60% OF OUR FACULTY
FULL TIME AND OR PART TIME.
OCCASIONS RIVERSIDE COMMITTEE
COLLEGE DISTRICT IS WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO ADDRESS DIVERSITY
AMONGST FACULTY AS OUR MEMBERS
ALSO SIMILAR TO THAT OF THE
STATE. ON BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE
COMING TO COLLEGE DISTRICT AND
THIS BOTTLE OF. TRUSTEES ITS
MANAGEMENT IT'S STUDENTS.
PRESIDENT UNDERSTANDING MYSELF
EXTEND THE WARMEST WELCOME. TO
THE GERMANS FOR HOSTING THIS
HEARING TODAY ON RTC THANK YOU
FOR A CALL FROM SUPPORT AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP
AND WE WISH YOU A LIVELY A
PRODUCTIVE HEARING TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THE CHANCELLOR
YOU SUCK. GOOD MORNING.
CHANCELLOR SAID I'M ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JOSE MEDINA CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND IT REALLY IS MY
PLEASURE TO BE HERE BACK AT
RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE- A
PLACE WHERE I WAS NOT ONLY A
STUDENT WAY BACK BUT ALSO
FACULTY MEMBER OF THE HISTORY
DEPARTMENT HERE AT RCC. SO AS
WE CAN IN THIS MORNING TO TALK
ABOUT DIVERSITY. THIS IS THE
THIRD THIRD ONE OF THE HEARINGS
ON DIVERSITY I HAD FIRST THE
ONE WITH THE UC CAMPUS AND THEN
ONE WITH CSU AND NOW THIS THIRD
ONE HERE WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. IT IS EIGHT SOMETHING
CLOSE TO MY HEART. AS A
LIFELONG TEACHER COMMITTED TO
ALL STUDENTS FOR MAKING SURE
SUCCESS ALL STUDENTS SUCCEED
STUDENTS WILL NOT SUCCEED
UNLESS WE GET TO A POINT WHERE
THE FACULTY REFLECTS THE
POPULATION. AND I KNOW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FOR ABOUT
BEST PRACTICES AND- AND HERE OF
HOW WE'RE MOVING FORWARD THAT
IT IS SOMETHING VERY IMPORTANT
TO ME PERSONALLY AND ALSO TO
THE LEGISLATURE. SO I WANT TO
EXTEND IT THANK YOU TO
RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR HOSTING US A
SPECIAL THANK YOU TO CHANCER
ESAU. PRESIDENT ANDERSON
PRESIDENT OF RCC MEDI SAY
YEAGER WHO I BELIEVE IS NOT
WITH US TODAY ENGINE NOW
WORKMEN. AND THANK YOU ALL OF
YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY. A
NOTE THAT THIS HEARING IS LIVE
STREAM AND WILL BE ARCHIVED IN
THE CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY
WEBSITE. ADDITIONALLY THE
MATERIALS DISCUSS AND HANDED
OUT TODAY CAN BE FOUND ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AT TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THIS COMMITTEE
HELD A OVERSIGHT HEARING TO
BEGIN THE CONVERSATION TO HOW
TO INCREASE FAST FACULTY
DIVERSITY IN ALL THREE SEGMENTS
SYSTEM WIDE. PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SEGMENTS- END UCC
ISSUE AND CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE THIS HEARING IS A
FOLLOW UP BUT WILL FOCUS SOLELY
ON THE FOR A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. RESEARCH SHOWS WHAT WE
KNOW THAT A DIVERSE FACULTY
CONTRIBUTES TO THE SUCCESS OF A
DIVERSE STUDENT BODY AND
IMPROVES THE OVERALL CAMPUS
CLIMATE. YET AS A CHANCER
POINTED OUT THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT LACK OF DIVERSITY
AMONG THE FACULTY AT AMERICA'S
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES BLACK
AND LATINO FACULTY ARE
PARTICULARLY UNDER REPRESENTED.
THE PART TIME AND FULL TIME
FACULTY RANKS. THE PERCENTAGE
OF UN REPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS HOWEVER HAS CONTINUED
TO GROW STEADILY. NEVER THE
LESS DESPITE NUMEROUS EFFORTS
TO IMPROVE FACULTY DIVERSITY
PROGRESS TO INCREASE THE
PROPORTION OF FEMALE AND UNDER
REPRESENTED MINORITY FACULTY
HAS BEEN SLOW. IN THE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
BUDGET ACT THE ASSEMBLY
SUCCESSIVELY ADVOCATED FOR SIX
MILLION DOLLARS TWO MILLION
DOLLARS EACH FOR THE U. S. C.
YES YOU AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
TO SUPPORT WHEN PLAYING BEST
PRACTICES AND TO REPORT ON THE
RACIAL AND ETHNIC AND GENDER
COMPOSITION. OF FACULTY. THIS
HEARING WILL REVIEW THE STATUS
OF FACULTY DIVERSIFICATION
EFFORTS AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR MYSELF AND MY
COLLEAGUE CRISTINA GARCIA WHO
WILL BE JOINING US IN A LITTLE
BIT. TO LEARN HOW THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AS USE THESE FUNDS TO
ADDRESS FACULTY DIVERSITY
SYSTEM WIDE AND TO LEARN OF
SOME OF THE CAMPUS IS BEST.
EFFORTS AS WELL. TO NOTE LAST
YEAR THIS COMMITTEE HELD A
HEARING ON THE TOPIC COVERING
THE UC. THE NEXT LEGISLATIVE
SESSION THIS COMMAND COMMITTEE
WILL CONVENE AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING. ON THE SAME TOPIC FOR
THE CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM. LASTLY THIS IS A BUSY
TIME FOR MANY MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE I KNOW SEVERAL
WANTED TO ATTEND THIS HEARING
BUT HAD. PRIOR COMMITMENTS.
SOME LEGISLATORS- AND BILLY
WILL BE SENDING THEIR STAFF-
NOT SURE THAT I SEE RACHEL-
GONZAGA HERE YET THIS MORNING
FROM. SHE'S HERE THERE'S IS
RACHEL. RACHEL FROM ASSEMBLY
WOMAN SABRINA CERVANTES AND
JACQUI ESCOBAR- AND SHE JACQUI
ALSO HEAR FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ IS OFFICE THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE BOTH OF YOU. SO
ON THE FIRST PANEL WE WILL
BEGIN WITH THE OVERVIEW OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF FACULTY DIVERSITY
AND THE LEGAL LANDSCAPE. OUR
FIRST SPEAKERS TODAY WILL
PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW OF THE
IMPORTANCE OF FACULTY DIVERSITY
AND THE CURRENT LEGAL LANDSCAPE
SO AT THIS TIME I'D LIKE TO
BRING UP AND WELCOME- THE FIRST
PANEL. BEGINNING WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF PHIL HILL COLLEGE.
TWEET T. WHEN N. MICHELLE SEE
KETTLES PRESIDENT OF THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY WELCOME BOTH AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US
HERE THIS MORNING. YOU MAY
BEGIN. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR. MORNING ALSO TO CHANCE
THIRTY SOUTH OF PRESIDENT A
ANDERSON MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
AND ALSO MEANT THAT THE VIEWING
PUBLIC MY NAME WHEN I'M
PRESIDENT OF FOOTHILL COLLEGE
AND ALL I COME TO YOU- BECAUSE
OF MY ROLE IN TERMS OF MY
BACKGROUND AS A DESEGREGATION
LAWYER ALL HAVING ALSO SERVED
AS THE INTRO AND A GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE STATE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ALONG WITH
BEING A COLLEGE PRESIDENT AND
SEEN SOME OF THE WORK OF
DIVERSIFYING OUR FACULTY AT
PLAY- I WILL FOLLOW A LITTLE
BIT OF- THE- POWER POINT
PRESENTATION THAT I THAT IS IN
YOUR PACKET. BUT I WOULD FIRST
OF ALL WANTED THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE LASER FOCUS
ATTENTION ON FACULTY DIVERSITY-
I KNOW WE HAVE DONE- ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF PROGRAM- AND IDEAS-
ACCEPT OR AROUND THE STATE IN
THE STATE IN THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ALSO IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AROUND OF RACIAL
EQUITY- IN CLOSING THE RACIAL
EQUITY GAS. AND FACULTY
DIVERSITY IS ACTUALLY ONE OF
THE MOST PROMISING STRATEGIES
IF NOT DE PROMISING STRATEGY
THAT DIRECTLY ADDRESSES THE
ISSUE OF RACE AND DIRECTLY.
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF THE
RACIAL EQUITY. AND SO THIS IS
IF ANYTHING THE MOST I IN MY
EYES THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUE
TO FOCUS ON AND SO THANK YOU
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP TO FOCUS ON
IT IT IS. IMPORTANT FROM SO
MANY ANGLES BUT MOSTLY
IMPORTANT FOR STUDENTS EQUITY
AND THE RESEARCH AS YOU MENTION
IS SHOWN AND I LIKE TO GO TO
OVER THAT RESEARCH A LITTLE BIT
BECAUSE IT'S REALLY CRITICAL.
AND THAT IS THAT STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THE EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS
OF A DIVERSE FACULTY NOW WE'VE
SEEN A SURGE IN HIGHER ED IN
OTHER SYSTEMS IN K. TWELVE- BUT
THERE IS ACTUALLY EVEN RESEARCH
IN A CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. AND THAT IS A RESEARCH
THAT WAS DONE SEVERAL YEARS AGO
AT DE ANZA COLLEGE WHO IS
ACTUALLY CONDUCTED BY A AN
ECONOMICS PROFESSOR. UC SANTA
CRUZ AND HE WAS COMING TO
DENOUNCE THE TO JUST TAKE A
LOOK AT THEIR DATA TO TAKE A
LOOK AT ACTUALLY ISSUES OF
POVERTY AND WORK FORCE AND
WHETHER IT WAS CREATED SOCIAL
MOBILITY. AND IN HIS DATA
ANALYSIS HE DISCOVERED
SOMETHING THAT HE HADN'T
INTENDED TO DISCOVER AND THAT
WAS THAT WHEN STUDENTS ARE
TAUGHT BY FACULTY OF COLOR. THE
RACIAL EQUITY GAP- WAS
PARTICULARLY STUDENT SUCCESS A
DATA CLOSES ANY CLOSES FROM
NINETEEN TO FIFTY ONE PERCENT-
AND THAT IS NOT NEW NEWS TO US
BUT WHAT IS EXTRAORDINARY IS
HOW MUCH- THE DATA WAS VERY.
SPECIFIC AND VERY FOCUSED AND
PARTICULARLY FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FOR MANY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN THE STATE
IF WE ARE ABLE. ACTUALLY IS A
CLOSURE FOR A GOOD NUMBER OF
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN TERMS
OF EQUITY THAT'S WHY THIS FOCUS
IS SO CRITICAL- SO THE
RESEARCHER ASK QUESTIONS LIKE
DO UNDER REPRESENTED MINORITY
STUDENTS PERFORM BETTER IN
KHÔNG CLASSES TAUGHT BY
MINORITY INSTRUCTORS. DO
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS DO
BETTER IN CLASSES TAUGHT BY
AFRICAN AMERICAN INSTRUCTORS SO
HE WAS ALSO EVEN TAKING A LOOK
AT THE RACE TO RACE DYNAMIC- DO
LATINO STUDENTS TO BETTER IN
COURSES TAUGHT BY LATINO
INSTRUCTORS AND HOW MUCH. DOES
THIS REPRESENT IN TERMS OF
DOING BETTER AND SO IN THE-
PRESENTATION YOU'LL SEE SOME
REALLY QUICK SNAPSHOTS OF HOW
HE SAW JUST PEER DATA. PEER
DATA ANALYSIS THAT HE SAW GAPS
CLOSING AND THIS IS HIS
CONCLUSION STRONG POSITIVE REAL
BUS MINORITY INTERACTION
EFFECTS FOR ALL OUTCOMES EXAM.
INCLUDING LONG TERM OUTCOMES
WHAT HE'S ALSO NOTICED THAT
STUDENTS WHO ARE TAUGHT. BY A
CHEMISTRY FACULTY OF COLOR ARE
MORE LIKELY TO EVEN MAJOR IN
CHEMISTRY. AND SOLD THAT ALSO
IS QUITE EXTRAORDINARY- HE SAW
PARTICULARLY STRONG RACE OF
RACE OWN OWN RACE INTERACTIONS
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS
HAVING THE HIGHEST- OF
PERFORMANCE WHEN TAUGHT BY AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN. FACULTY
ALTHOUGH EVEN LATINO STUDENTS
WERE PERFORMING VERY WELL IT
TAUGHT BY AN AFRICAN AMERICAN
FACULTY AND SO THE INTERACTION
OF RACE IS ACTUALLY QUITE
EXTRANET NOW. I'M NOT SURPRISED
BY THIS DATA BECAUSE IF YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT THE KEY TWELVE
DATA IT ALSO SHOWS THAT IN FACT
WHEN A FACULTY OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY AFRICAN AMERICAN
FACULTY TEACHES- DE ELLAS
STUDENT SUCCESS RATE INCREASES
FOR ALL STUDENTS INCLUDING.
CAUCASIAN STUDENTS SO QUITE
EXTRAORDINARY AND WHAT HE SAW
WAS. THERE WAS THIS ROLE MODEL
AFFECT IT. NOT LIKE THE FACULTY
OF COLLEGE ANYTHING DIFFERENT.
THEY DIDN'T DO ANYTHING
DIFFERENT BUT IT'S HOW THE
STUDENTS SOLVE THE FACULTY AND
THE ROLE MODEL AFFECT THAT CAME
WITH THAT- THE FULL ARTICLE IS
ALSO IN THE PRESENTATION. AND
THEN IT REALLY QUICKLY THERE IS
NO DOUBT DIVERSEY ALSO HELPS
IMPROVE THE TEAM SO THE
FUNCTION OF THE COLLEGE AS A
COLLEGE PRESIDENT TEAM WORK AS
THEY SAY MAKES THE DREAM WORK
RIGHT BUT TEAM WORK IS ONLY
POSSIBLE IN TERMS OF
INNOVATION. NEW PERSPECTIVES
FRESHNESS OF IT IDEAS BEING
ABLE TO SAY THINGS THAT MAYBE
OTHERS WOULD SAY. THAT IS FROM
DIVERT. ALL TYPES OF DIVERSITY
BUT ALSO RACIAL DIVERSITY AND
SO THERE IS A STUDY BY
MACKENZIE THAT SHOWS EVEN
RACIAL AND GENDER DIVERSE THE
HELP COMPANIES WITH THEIR
BOTTOM LINE- AND SO THAT IS
WORTH WORTH TAKING A LOOK AT TO.
L. SO THEN IF WE ALL KNOW THAT
THIS IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO
FOR OUR STUDENTS THEN THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO WE DO IT X.
SPECIALLY IN LIGHT OF LEGAL.
PARAMETERS AND CONSTRUCTIONS
THAT WE HAVE AND WE KNOW THAT
WHAT PROP TWO WILL NINE SAYS IN
TERMS OF A PROHIBITION AGAINST
PREFERENCE BASED ON RACE AND
GENDER. BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT
IN THIS WORK IT'S TWO SIDES OF
THE KIDS SAME POINT I OFTEN
DESCRIBE IT TWO SIDES OF THE
SAME COIN. SO ONE SIDE
PROHIBITS YOU FROM
DISCRIMINATION EVEN BEFORE PROP
TILL NINE THERE WAS ALREADY NON
DISCRIMINATION LAWS. RIGHT BUT
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE COIN IS
EQUAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
ENSURING THAT EVERYONE HAS AN
EQUAL FAIR SHAKE NO MATTER WHAT
THEIR RACE NO MATTER WHAT THEIR
GENDER. HE IN THE HIRING
EMPLOYMENT PROCESS AND SO- IN
HERE IT ALSO SPEAKS TO A LITTLE
BIT OF THE LEGISLATIVE MANDATE
AROUND A DIVERSE WORKFORCE- IT
ALSO TALKS ABOUT TITLE FIVE.
AND THE REQUIREMENTS OF UP IN
THE REGULATIONS AROUND HAVING A
DIVERSE WORKFORCE SO THERE IS
NO DOUBT THAT OUR OUR LAWS
HAVE. HAVE BEEN ABLE TO REFLECT
THE OTHER SIDE OF THE COIN THAT
IS THE EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY AND THE REQUIREMENT
FOR TRAINING. AND SPECIFICALLY
OUR REGULATIONS EVEN REQUIRE
TRAININGS AROUND IN PLACE HI
YES- AND THAT IS SOMETHING I
THINK IS ALSO ANOTHER STRATEGY
THAT FOLKS NEED TO FOCUS ON-
THE NOTION OF UNCONSCIOUS BIAS.
AND MORE TO COME ON THAT.
DURING MY TIME AT THE STATE
CHAMBERS OFFICE I DID WRITE A
LEGAL OPINION. AROUND EQUAL
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
WHAT IF BUT NOT WHAT YOU CAN'T
DO BUT WHAT YOU CAN DO. TO
INSURE RACIAL DIVERSITY AND SO
FOLKS CAN TAKE A LOOK AT THAT
MEMEL BUT AT THE. END OF THE
MUMBLE PARTICULARLY POINTS OUT.
AN ANALYTICAL PATHWAY. AND I
ASKED THE STATE LEGISLATURE
ALONG WITH COLLEAGUES TO TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT ANALYTICAL PATHWAY
BECAUSE IT TALKS ABOUT FOR
INSTANCE THE NOTION OF ADVERSE
IMPACT. IT TALKS ABOUT WHAT WE
CALL THE FOUR FIFTHS RULE WHICH
IS THE 8020% RULE IT'S AN
ANALYTICAL WAY TO KNOW WHETHER
THERE ARE. POSSIBLE RACIAL
IMPACTS OF WHAT IS HAPPENING
AROUND THE EMPLOYMENT OF
PROCESS SO I THINK IT'S WORTH A
SPECIALLY AS WE GET MORE
SOPHISTICATED. IN THE WORK OF
FACULTY DIVERSITY HIRING OF YOU
KNOW I THINK OUR SYSTEM IN
GENERAL IS- IS VERY COMMITTED A
TO THE NOTION OF FACULTY
DIVERSITY I THINK OUR SYSTEM IN
GENERAL IS COMMITTED FROM A
FINANCIAL STANDPOINT. OF
FACULTY DIVERSITY BUT WE DO
NEED TO GET SOPHISTICATED
AROUND THE WORK BECAUSE WE ARE
GOING AGAINST POSSIBLE IMPLICIT
BIAS- AND THE LIKE- AND SO I
THINK IT'S REALLY CRITICAL TO
TAKE A LOOK AT IT FROM AN
ANALYTICAL STANDPOINT. AND
LASTLY JUST A QUICK COLLEGE
PRESIDENT PERSON. AND TO SOME
EXTENT- A LEGAL PERSPECTIVE-
THERE IS THIS NOTION CALLED A
TEST CALL THE IMPLICIT
ASSOCIATION TESTS. I THINK WE
REALLY TO GET SOPHISTIC SAID
IT'S AN ABILITY TO TEST
ANONYMOUSLY WHETHER ONE HAS
UNCONSCIOUS BIAS WITH REGARDS
TO RACE. AND THIS SHOULD BE
REALLY TAUGHT BECAUSE IF IT'S
UNCONSCIOUS EVEN IF YOU THINK
YOU ARE YES I'M AWARE I'M AND
CON I HAVE A CONSCIOUS BIAS.
YES OUR SOCIETY IS WORKING A
RAN AGAINST SYSTEM LIST OF
OPPRESSION AND PARTICULARLY
AROUND RACISM. I'LL BUT WHAT
CAN I DO. THE NOTION OF
IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING IS THAT
KNOWING IS NOT ENOUGH JUST
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THAT IS NOT
ENOUGH YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO
TAKE STEPS TO LOWER YOUR
INDIVIDUAL BIAS. AND THEY'RE
ACTUALLY ALSO STRATEGIES ON HOW
TO LOWERED THAT BIAS ON A DAILY
BASIS YOU ALMOST HAVE TO WORK-
AGAINST YOUR. UNCONSCIOUS BIAS
TO BE ABLE TO LOWER THAT BIAS.
THE LONGITUDINAL DATA TO
MENTION TO YOU I THINK IT'S
CRITICAL TO GET SOPHISTICATED
AROUND THIS WORK AND THE NOTION
THAT THE EMPLOYMENT HIRING AND
THE STUDENT EQUITY PLAN SHOULD
ACTUALLY BE INTEGRATED WE
SHOULD SEAT BECAUSE- IN ORDER
TO CLOSE TO STUDENT EQUITY GAP
WE NEED FACULTY DIVERSITY. AND
SO THEREFORE FAULTY DIVERSITY
IS A STRATEGY IN STUDENT EQUITY
WORK AND THEREFORE IT NEEDS TO
BE INTEGRATED IN THAT WAY IT
SHOULD BE TWO HOUSES IT
SHOULDN'T BE TOO PLANTS- THE
OTHER IS ALSO I SUBMIT TO YOU
WE HAVE A LARGE NUMBER PART
TIME FACULTY. THERE'S BEEN A
LOT OF FOCUS ON TIME FACULTY
HIRING BUT THE PART TIME
FACULTY HIRING HAS ACTUALLY
BEEN- UNDER THE RADAR SO TO
SPEAK AND I THINK THERE NEEDS
TO BE SOME ATTENTION AROUND
THAT HIRING A PART TIME FACULTY
ALSO IN OUR SYSTEM- AND- I KNOW
OUR SYSTEM IS GOING TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT REQUEST FOR
FUNDING. I THINK THAT'S REALLY
CRITICAL AS WE BRING MORE
PEOPLE ON THE BUS THAT'S WHERE
THE STRATEGIES OF ALL THIS WORK
COULD BE VERY IMPACTFUL. AND
LASTLY I WANTED THANK YOU ONE
OF THE TWELVE STRATEGIES TO
LOWER IMPLICIT BIAS BASED
RESEARCH IS THAT WE MONITOR.
IMPLICIT BIAS WHEN YOU PUT
PEOPLE UNDER A WHAT IS ON FMRI
TO SEE WHETHER THEY'RE BIASED
GOES UP. IF YOU TELL THEM THAT
I AM MONITORING YOU FOR
IMPLICIT BIAS THE PIE IS GOES
DOWN. AND SO THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING TO MONITOR. SYSTEM
Y. EIGHT WIDE THE WORK THAT WE
DO AS ALLEGE PRESIDENTS TO
MONITOR COLLEGE WIDE IS
CRITICAL TO ACTUALLY LOWERING.
IMPLICIT BIAS ITSELF SO PLEASE
KEEP FOCUSED ON THAT AND THE.
MORE THAN HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING AFTERNOON- GOOD
MORNING CHAIR MEDINA- AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE YOU
FOR GIVING ME A CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY THE- AREA
SHARE WITH YOU- OUR THOUGHTS ON
THIS REALLY IMPORTANT TOPIC AND
A SPECIAL THANKS TO PRESIDENT
WHEN WHO I THINK CAPTURED- IT
PERFECTLY BY. SAYING IT IS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO FOR STUDENTS
AND I THINK EVERY TIME WE HAVE
A CONVERSATION ABOUT HIGHER
EDUCATION THAT IT SHOULD. BE
THE GUIDING LIGHT THAT CENTERS
ALL OUR WORK. I'M MICHELLE SEE
KATO'S I'M PRESIDENT AT THE
CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY OR SOLE FOCUS AND
MISSION IS TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS WHO GO
TO COLLEGE. ENSURE THAT WINSTON
ONCE THEY GET TO COLLEGE
WHETHER IT'S A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE A CAL STATE OR YOU SEE.
THAT THEY REACH THEIR COLLEGE
GOALS AND GRADUATE. AND WITHIN
THAT. MISSION AT OUR VERY HEART
AND CENTER IS ENSURING EQUITY
AND CLOSING OF THE PERSISTENT.
INEQUITABLE HIGHER EDUCATION-
GAPS THAT EXIST. IN ALL OF OUR
SYSTEMS OF PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION. LAST YEAR AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW WE RELEASED A GROUND
BEEF GROUND BREAKING REPORT ON
THE IMPORTANCE OF RACIAL AND
GENDER INCLUSION IN HIGHER
EDUCATION. AND WHY IT MATTERS
FOR STUDENT SUCCESS THE REPORT
ANALYZED- STUDENT DIVERSITY
FACULTY DIVERSITY SENIOR
LEADERSHIP DIVERSITY- AND THE
DIVERSITY OF ACADEMIC SENATE'S-
MANY OF YOU CAN FIND THIS
REPORT IT'S CALLED LEFT OUT HOW
INCLUSION IN CALIFORNIA'S
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES HURTS
OUR VALUES OUR STUDENTS AND OUR
ECONOMY. AND ONLINE YOU CAN
LOOK UP ANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CAL STATE ARE YOU SEE CAMPUS
AND ACTUALLY SEE- DIVERSITY
NUMBERS FOR THE STUDENT
POPULATION AND ALL THE OTHER
GROUPS THAT I JUST SHARED WITH
YOU. ONE ONLY NEEDS TO REALLY
SET FOOT IN ANY ONE OF OUR
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO SEE THE
DIVERSITY OF OUR STUDENTS- 69%
OF STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA
HIGHER EDUCATION OUR STUDENTS
OF COLOR. THAT NUMBER IS ONLY
GOING TO GROW AS WE HAVE OVER
76% OF STUDENTS OF COLOR IN K.
TWELVE SO YOU CAN SEE WHY THIS
IS SO CRITICAL AND IMPOSE OUR
REPORT AND OUR RESEARCH AND
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE PROBABLY
SEEN IT BEFORE YOU WILL NOT BE
SURPRISING. ALTHOUGH OUR
STUDENTS ARE DIVERSE OUR
FACULTY CERTAINLY ARE NOT
ALTHOUGH OUR STUDENTS ARE
DIVERT OUR ACADEMIC SENATE'S
ARE NOT. ALTHOUGH OUR STUDENTS
ARE DIVERSE OUR LEADERSHIP IS
NOT. TODAY I WILL HIGHLIGHT
SOME OF THESE NUMBERS FOR YOU I
JUST WANT TO KNOW THAT THE DATA
COLLECTED WAS TWENTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN. AND YOU CAN
SEE SOME OF THE DATA I REFER TO
AN EXECUTIVE SUMMARIES THAT YOU
WERE PROVIDED EARLIER. BUT I
ALSO WANT TO START FROM A
REALLY PERSONAL PLACE AS THE
FIRST IN MY FAMILY TO GO TO
COLLEGE AS A FIRST AND STUDENT
WHEN I ARRIVED AT MY CAMPUS
PITZER COLLEGE NOT TOO FAR FROM
HEARING. ON'T NOT THAT FAR FROM
THE DIVERSE LOS ANGELES I GREW
UP IN NOT THAT FAR FROM THE
DIVERSE HIGH SCHOOL I ATTENDED-
BUT IT WAS PRETTY STRIKING TO
BE ON A CAMPUS WHERE I WAS ONE
OF VERY FEW- STUDENTS OF COLOR.
AND AS A FIRST GEN STUDENT IT
WAS CRITICAL FOR ME TO BE ABLE
TO SEE- MYSELF AS BELONGING
THERE AND I THINK THIS IS
REALLY CRITICAL IN THE RESEARCH
THAT YOU FIND ABOUT FIRST
GENERATION STUDENTS- A SENSE OF
BELONGING WILL MAKE IT OR BREAK
IT FOR STUDENT IN TERMS OF
WHETHER THEY SUCCEED OR NOT. SO
WHETHER THEY HAVE ROLE MODELS
PEOPLE INVESTED IN THEM- AND
EVEN JUST PEOPLE THEY CAN LOOK
AT WHEN THEY SHOW UP IN CLASSES
THAT. MAY SHARE THEIR SAME
EXPERIENCE WE WANT TO SEE
OURSELVES IN THE FOLKS IN FRONT
OF US AND WHEN WE SEE OURSELVES
WE SEE THAT THE INSTITUTION
VALUES ARE EXPERIENCE BECAUSE
IT HIRES PEOPLE THAT COME FROM
OUR EXPERIENCE- WE KNOW THAT WE
ARE VALUED BECAUSE WE ARE
REPRESENTED- ALL HUMAN
CONNECTION STARTS WITH THE IDEA
OF FINDING SOMETHING IN COMMON.
AND. LIVING IN A DIVERSE STATE
LIKE CALIFORNIA. THE FIND IN
COMMON TO A VARIETY OF THINGS
BUT ALL STUDENTS BENEFIT FROM
HAVING DIVERSE FACULTY SO I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT
WHILE IT'S POWERFUL FOR FIRST
CHEN. STUDENTS OF COLOR TO SEE
FACULTY OF COLOR THAT LOOK LIKE
THEM THAT REFLECT THEIR
EXPERIENCE THAT'S IMPORTANT FOR
WHITE STUDENTS TO HAVE WHITE
STUDENTS SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEE
LET NEXT FACULTY. AFRICAN
AMERICAN FACULTY ASIAN AMERICAN
FACULTY SO WANT TO BE CLEAR
THAT THIS IS ABOUT WHAT'S GOOD
FOR A DIVERSE CALIFORNIA AND A
GLOBAL ECONOMY THAT WE ALL LIVE
IN. SO GIVING GIVEN THE GROWING
DIVERSITY OF OUR STATE YOU KNOW
WE THOUGHT IT WAS REALLY-
IMPORTANT TO DO THIS RESEARCH
AND ANALYSIS. OFTENTIMES I
THINK YOU'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH
OUR STATE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
REPORTS WHICH LOOK AT STUDENTS
HOW MANY STUDENTS OF COLOR ARE
THERE THAT ARE PREPARED FOR
COLLEGE HOW MANY GO TO COLLEGE
WE HAVE A STATE OF HIGHER ED
REPORT FOR LOT NEXT. STATE OF
HIGHER ED REPORT FOR BLACK
STUDENTS. HAD REPORT FOR ASIAN
AMERICAN. AND HOPEFULLY IN THE
COMING YEAR YOU'LL SEE A STATE
OF HIGHER ED REPORT FOR NATIVE
AMERICAN STUDENTS WE DO THOSE
REPORTS BECAUSE WE BELIEVE THAT
INSTITUTION SHOULD CARE ABOUT
HOW THEY BETTER PREPARE. AND
SUPPORT STUDENTS REGARDLESS OF
BACKGROUND. AND ARE INTENTIONAL
IN THAT WAY AS WE DID THOSE
REPORTS WE REALIZE THAT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO PUT AMERICA ON
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION AS
WELL. TO SEE HOW IS NOT JUST
THE DIVERSITY OF THE INCOMING
STUDENT BODY AND WHAT THEIR
SUCCESS RATES ARE BUT WHAT IS
THE DIVERSITY IN REPRESENTATION
EXIST IN OUR PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS. SO AS I
SHARED EARLIER IN SPITE OF
REALLY BROAD DIVERSITY WE HAVE
OVER TWO POINT TWO MILLION
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN PUBLIC. IN
OUR COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALONE
44% OF STUDENTS ARE LOT NEXT
TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT. RIGHT 14%
OR ASIAN AMERICAN NATIVE
HAWAIIAN OR PACIFIC ISLANDER
AND 6% ARE AFRICAN AMERICAN.
YET DESPITE THAT RICH DIVERSITY
OF OUR STUDENT BODY WE HAVE A
TRUE LACK OF DIVERSITY IN BOTH
TENURED AND NON. TENURED
FACULTY POSITIONS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AS YOU CAN.
THE HAND OUT THE STE. NO THE
TENURED FACULTY COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE 61% WHITE. 15%
MONEX ONLY 10% ASIAN AMERICAN
NATIVE HAWAIIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDER 6% AFRICAN AMERICAN.
THE STORY OF NON TENURED
FACULTY AT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IS NOT MUCH DIFFERENT
60% WHITE. IT'S A DIFFERENCE OF
PERCENT FROM TENURED FACULTY
ARE 13% LOT NEXT 11% ASIAN
AMERICAN NATIVE HAWAIIAN AND 5%
AFRICAN AMERICAN. I LIKE TO
SHARE BOTH TENURED AND NON TEN
BECAUSE- OFTEN YOU WILL HEAR
THAT THE INCOMING PIPELINE OF
FACULTY IS MORE DIVERSE THE
DATA WE ANALYZED DOES NOT.
PROVE THAT TO BE ACCURATE AND I
THINK PRESIDENT WHEN- MENTIONED
THAT IN HER COMMENTS IF THE
PIPELINE IS NON TENURED FACULTY
AND THAT PIPELINE IS ACTUALLY
EITHER AS- LACKING IN DIVERSITY
AS ARE TENURED FACULTY- HOW ARE
WE GOING TO PRODUCE IN ANY NEAR
FUTURE- DIVERSE REFLECTIVE.
REPRESENTATIVE FACULTY FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. RACIAL
INEQUITIES IN FACULTY
REPRESENTATION ARE FURTHER
COMPOUNDED IN REPRESENTATION AT
ACADEMIC SENATE'S FOR CAMPUSES
AND FOR THE SYSTEM ITSELF THIS
IS CONCERNING GIVEN THE ROLE
ACADEMIC SENATE'S PLAY AN
ESTABLISHING POLICIES WHICH CAN
DRAMATICALLY IMPACT THE ABILITY
FOR STUDENTS. ESPECIALLY
STUDENTS OF COLOR TO ACCESS AND
THRIVE AT COLLEGES. IN YOUR
PACKET YOU WILL ALSO FIND BRIEF
THAT LOOKS AT AND TATIAN OF
CAMPUS AND SYSTEMWIDE ACADEMIC
SENATE'S ACADEMIC SENATE'S ARE
AMONG THOSE CRITICAL LEADERSHIP
BODIES THAT EXERCISE
SIGNIFICANT DUTIES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES POWERS AND
ALLEGES ACROSS. ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CERTAINLY
TRUE ALSO AT OUR CS YOU WHEN
YOU SEE. ONE EXAMPLE OF
ACADEMIC DECISION MAKING IS ANY
CURRENT DEGREE CHANGES FOR
INSTANCE CHANGES TO COURSE
REQUIREMENTS FOR A MAJOR MUST
BE APPROVED BY THE ACADEMIC
SENATE ANY PROPOSAL TO
ESTABLISH A NEW MAJOR OR TO
DISCONTINUE A MAJOR MUST BE
APPROVED BY THE ACADEMIC
SENATE. AND WE SEE ACADEMIC
SENATE'S AFFAIRS AT THE CSU
PUSHING FOR NEW ADMISSIONS
REQUIREMENTS THAT AS MOST OF
YOU ON THIS COMMITTEE NOW WE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO. IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR THOSE IN
POSITIONS TO INFLUENCE ACADEMIC
POLICY SO SIGNIFICANT TO
UNDERSTAND THE EXPERIENCES OF
THE STUDENTS THE IMPACT. IT
AGAIN WE SEE A MISMATCH A
REPRESENTATION BETWEEN WHO SITS
ON THE BODIES AND THE STUDENTS
THEY SERVE. 72% OF CAMPUS
ACADEMIC SENATE MEMBERS ARE
WHITE. 14% OUR LAND NEXT 7% ARE
ASIAN AMERICAN NAY WHY AND
PACIFIC ISLANDER AND ONLY 5%
ARE AFRICAN. THE ONE BRIGHT
NOTE OUR RESEARCH DID FIND WAS
THAT THERE WAS GREATER GENDER
EQUITY AND REPRESENTATION
ESPECIALLY A CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BETWEEN
STUDENTS AND FACULTY. MORE THAN
HALF OF OUR STUDENTS AT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE 53% ARE
FEMALE. AND WOMEN ARE AT OR
ABOVE REPRESENTATIONAL EQUITY
IN TEN YEAR TO NON TENURED
FACULTY POSITIONS AND WITHIN
THE ACADEMIC SENATE 54% OF
TENURED FACULTY ARE FEMALE
FIFTY AND 53% OF NON TENURED
FACULTY ARE FEMALE. WE OFTEN
HEAR THE PEOPLE APPRECIATE AND
WANT DIVERSITY HOWEVER AS THIS
DATA SHOWS AND I THINK AS THE
CHANCELLOR- OPENED WE OFTEN
JUST GIVE LIP SERVICE TO THAT
COMMENT. I'M WE'VE COMPLETELY
TOLERATED THE ABSENCE OF
DIVERSITY AMONGST OUR FACULTY
AND LEADERSHIP THAT OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS CHAIR MEDINA YOU
HAVE RIGHTLY LAMENTED THESE
CHALLENGES AND THAT CHANGE IS
NOT HAPPENING FAST ENOUGH. WE
HOPE THAT TODAY PROVIDES AN
OPPORTUNITY TO NOT ONLY BRING
FOR THEIR ATTENTION ON THE NEED
TO URGENTLY MAKE AN ACADEMIC
SENATE POSITIONS MORE
INCLUSIVE. BUT ALSO IDENTIFY
PRACTICAL NEXT STEPS TOWARDS
THAT END SO WE OFFER SOME
ACTIONABLE STEPS THAT WE THINK
YOU CAN HELP MOVE FORWARD.
FIRST OBVIOUSLY THE STATE NEEDS
TO COMMIT TO RACIAL AND GENDER
EQUITY IN HIGHER EDUCATION
THROUGH ITS OWN POLICY AND
BUDGETARY ACTIONS. THE STATE
SHOULD SET SPECIFIC INTRACTABLE
GOALS FOR IMPROVING FACULTY
DIVERSITY AMONG OUR PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEMS.
OTHERWISE WE LACK OF VISION FOR
HOW WE EXPECT OUR INSTITUTIONS
TO IMPROVE AND WILL ACCEPT
INCREMENTAL CHANGE WHICH IS ALL
WE'VE EVER GOTTEN. WE MUST ALSO
BE PUBLIC AND TRANSPARENT ABOUT
THE GOAL OF INCREASED RACIAL
DIVERSITY AMONG FACULTY WILL
TESTING RESOURCES FOR THAT
PURPOSE AS YOU'VE DONE
RECENTLY. INVESTMENT SHOULD
COME WITH CLEAR ACCOUNTABILITY
GOALS AND METRICS IN EVALUATING
EVALUATING VACANCY. RESOURCES
ALONE ARE UNLIKELY TO YIELD THE
DESIRED OUTCOMES WE WANT. WE
NEED BETTER DATA AND
TRANSPARENCY ON FACULTY AND
LEADERSHIP REPRESENTATION BY
RACE BY ETHNICITY AND BY GENDER
MUST BE STRENGTHENED AND
STREAMLINED AS WE GET THIS DATA
SO THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY MONITOR
WHICH WAS ONE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS PRESIDENT WHEN
ALSO SHE- THE STATE. SHOULD
WORK TOGETHER WITH THE EXPERTS
TO DEVELOP A FRAMEWORK FOR ALL
PUBLIC COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO REPORT ON THE
RACIAL ETHNIC AND GENDER
REPRESENTATION OF FACULTY BOTH
TENURED AND NON TENURED. THEY
ALREADY HAVE TO REPORT THAT TO
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WHY ARE
WE COLLECTING IT FOR OUR STATE
GOVERNMENT WE SHOULD ALSO
REQUIRE THAT ACADEMIC SENATE'S
IN SENIOR LEADERSHIP REPORT
THIS DATA. THEY ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO REPORT IT. HOW ELSE
CAN YOU MEASURE PROGRESS. AT A
CAMPUS LEVEL CAMPUSES SHOULD BE
REQUIRED TO ESTABLISH CAMPUS
GOALS WITH SPECIFIC PLANS. AND
MILESTONES FOR CLOSING RACIAL
DIVERSITY GAPS AN INCREASING
REPRESENTATION AMONG FACULTY
AND CAMPUS LEADERSHIP. WE ALSO
KNOW THAT RESEARCH AND PRACTICE
LIKE THAT OF U. S. C. CENTER
FOR URBAN EDUCATION THE CAMPUS
IS ALSO NEED TO COMPLETELY
RESTRUCTURE THEIR HIRING
PROCESS AND FUNDAMENTALLY
CHANGE THE ROLE OF HUMAN
RESOURCES FROM THE CONTENT OF A
POSITION ANNOUNCEMENT TO THE
OUTRAGE THEY CONDUCT ON THOSE
POSITION ANNOUNCEMENTS. TO
CHANGING THE INTERVIEW
QUESTIONS TO REALLY PROBING FOR
EQUITY MINDED COMPETENCIES
BECAUSE NOT ONLY DO WE WANT
DIVERSE PROFESSIONALS AT OUR
CAMPUSES WE WANT EQUITY MINDED
PROFESSIONALS AT OUR CAMPUSES.
WE SHOULD BE ASKING FOR
TEACHING DEMONSTRATIONS THAT
SPECIFICALLY DEMONSTRATE
KNOWLEDGE OF CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE PEDAGOGY. THERE'S A
LOT MORE THAT USC AND DOCTOR
STYLE OF AND SIMONE AND HER HER
GROUP CAN REALLY PROVIDE ON
THAT NOTE I ALSO JUST WANT TO-
TO SAY THAT SOMETIMES THE LEGAL
QUESTIONS THAT ARE RAISED
AROUND THE LIMITATIONS OF PROP
TWO OH NINE- ARE USED AS AN
EXCUSE FOR NOT BEING MORE
DIVERSE ON CAMPUS. AND I WOULD
LIKE US TO BE BRAVE AND BOLD TO
FLIP THE QUESTION I DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW SOME CAMPUSES
CAN HAVE TWENTY OPEN POSITIONS
FILL ALL TWENTY POSITIONS WITH
ONLY WHITE FACULTY AND NOT BE
THREATENED WITH THE CONCERN.
THAT MAYBE THEY ARE
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST FACULTY
OF COLOR SO INSTEAD OF ALWAYS
FEELING LIKE WE HAVE TO DEFEND
DIVERSITY I THINK CAMPUSES AND
CAMPUS LEADERS SHOULD BE IN A
POSITION TO DEFEND TO THEIR
LACK OF DIVERSITY. THE WORK IS
URGENT AND IMPORTANT AND I
REALLY THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU BOTH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATIONS- COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS ON PROCESS OF MAYBE
THE FIRST ONE FOR BOTH OF YOU-
IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH THE
CONCEPT OF CLUSTER HIRING. I
BELIEVE IT'S SOMETHING THAT IS
PRACTICE WITH WITHIN THE UC.
WHICH HAS A GOAL OF- HIRING.
THE GROUP OF PEOPLE PERHAPS
ACROSS- SPECTRUM OF COMPETENCY
USER DISCIPLINES. IF YOU COULD
MAYBE SPEAK MORE ABOUT THAT
IDEA OF CLUSTER HIRING AND IS
THAT SOMETHING THAT MIGHT BE
APPLICABLE TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. I'M WELL FAMILIAR
WITH THE CLOSER HIGH YOU WERE
OF RATHER RECENTLY- AND I THINK
IT'S WORTH- STUDY OF BID IF
THERE WAS AN ARTICLE IN THE
CHRONICLE OF HIGHER EDUCATION.
ON NATIONALLY AROUND THAT AL
AND I THINK IT'S WORTH
ANALYZING OF FOR THREE REASONS
ONE IT'S WORTH ANALYZING
WHETHER THEY WERE ABLE TO. DO
THAT WITHOUT VIOLATING PROP TWO
OH NINE WHICH IS THE NEW WANTS
OF CALIFORNIA THE SECOND IS
IT'S INTRIGUING. BECAUSE IT
FOCUSES ON AREAS OF NEED ALL
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES AROUND
NEW FUNDING COMING IN FOR
FACULTY HIRING. IS A AND
SOMETIMES WE SEE THAT DIVERSITY
RACIALLY- GROWING UP IS
ACTUALLY IN THE AREAS OF FOR
INSTANCE COUNSELING- BUT NOT IN
AREAS OF STEM TEACHING. AND SO
BEING ABLE TO DO CLOSER HIRING
THAT SAYS WE'RE GOING TO
CLUSTERS CERTAIN AREA LIKE STEM
OF FOR INSTANCE OF IS
INTRIGUING A AND IT'S WORTH OF
FOCUS EXPRESSION KNOWING OR
LACK OF DIVERSITY IN TOWN. SO
IF IT WAS A CLUSTER HIGHER. IN
INSTEAD IT IS THAT. IS TO SEE
WHETHER IS A AND AGAIN THIS IS
VERY NEW TO ME SO I THINK IT'S
VERY MUCH WORTH IT WANTED
TOWARD EXPORT WE SHOULD EXPLORE
ALL STRATEGIES- BUT THEN ALSO
TO SEE WHETHER IT MAKES SENSE
FOR OUR SYSTEM AS COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BECAUSE WE HAVE.
CONCEPTS OF FSA'S FACULTY
SERVICE AREAS AND A WHAT IS THE
ABILITY TO HIRE BROADLY OR
NARROWLY WITHIN THAT THOSE
CONFINES OF FACULTY AND OUR
FACULTY LEADERSHIP- I THINK
KNOWING THAT WOULD BE
INTERESTED. IN AT LEAST TAKING
A LOOK AND EXPLORING A WHAT
THAT MEANS VIS A VIS THE WAY
WERE STRUCTURE SO I DON'T KNOW
AND I CANNOT DEFINITIVELY SAY
IT'S A IT'S A RIGHT WAY TO GO
BUT IT'S DEFINITELY WORTH
EXPLORING. MISHA ARE THE
RESEARCH I'VE SEEN AS THE
CLUSTER HIRING ISN'T REALLY
STRATEGY I AGREE WITH AND ONE
THAT IT'S ABSOLUTELY WORTH
EXPLORING. YES ONE TOPIC THAT
WE'VE NOT DISCUSSED IS THE
REALITY THAT WHEN FACULTY THESE
ARE NOT VERY DIVERSE AND YOU
ONLY HIRE ONE FACULTY OF COLOR
THEIR EXPERIENCES SIMILAR TO
WHAT AT FIRST AND STUDENT
ARRIVING ON CAMPUS IS. AND SO
IT CAN'T JUST BE ABOUT HIRING A
DIVERSE POOL IT TO BE ABOUT
CREATING UGH BUT ENVIRONMENT
WHERE DIVERSE FACULTY OF COLOR
FEEL SUPPORTED AND WELCOMED.
AND I THINK CLUSTER HIRING
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
THAT. THAT WAS AN ACTUALLY BE
MY NEXT QUESTION WAS ABOUT
PERSISTENCE PERSISTENCE OF
FACULTY. AND THE EXPERIENCE OF
BEING THE ONLY ONE WOULD NOT. I
HAD A I DO NOT THINK OF MAKE
ONE YOU KNOW FEEL WE TALKED
ABOUT THE SENSE OF BELONGING-
AND THE SENSE OF. BEING PART OF
THE CAMPUS AND PERHAPS THE IDEA
OF A- CLUSTER HIRING WOULD
WOULD HELP. IN THAT AS WELL. I
IN A GOING BACK TO THE CLUSTER
HIRING IN THE ISSUE OF- FACULTY
THERE DIVERSE RACIALLY DIVERSE.
RETENTION OF THE CHURCHES WITH
AGAIN VERY MUCH INTERESTED IN
THE LORI BUT ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES THINKING THE COLLEGE
PRESIDENT. IS WE DON'T ACTUALLY
GET TO HIRE LARGE NUMBERS OF
FULL TIME FACULTY AND SO THE
NOTION OF CLUSTER- IS
LOGISTICALLY OF JUST PLAYING IT
IN MY MIND. AND SO THAT'S WHY I
THINK AN INFUSION OF MONEY TO
THE SYSTEM TO HIRE NEW FACULTY-
OTHERWISE RIGHT NOW IT'S A
SCENARIO WHEN FACULTY LEAVE AND
VACANCY STICKER. OF THE WITH
THE NEW FUSION OF MONEY INTO
NEW FACULTY HIRING WE MAY HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THE
CLUSTER HIRING SO JUST- JUST
WANT TO NOTE THAT. OF FACULTY
OF THAT PARTICULAR- DIVERSE
RACIALLY FACULTY OF- AND THEIR
RETENTION IS ACTUALLY A VERY
IMPORTANT NOTION WITHIN THE
CONCEPT OF EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY. AND IN FACT THERE
WAS A DISSERTATION THAT WAS
DONE IN THE ORANGE COUNTY LA AT
THE COLLEGES- IT ONE
DISSERTATION OF THE YEAR AND IT
SHOWED. OF THE ISOLATION THE
FACULTY OF COLOR HALF AND MANY
OF THEM IF THEY'RE NOT LEAVING-
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES- AND
DECIDE TO STILL STAY BECAUSE OF
THEIR LOVE FOR TEACHING. A MANY
OF THEM ACTUALLY DO NOT GET
INVOLVED IN LEADERSHIP SO NOT
INVOLVED IN THEIR LOCAL SENATE
NOT INVOLVED IN HIRING PROCESS
CEDAR CHESTS TEACHING AND
FINING THAT LOVE TO THE
TEACHING AND NOT SERVING THE
COLLEGE COMMUNITY. BECAUSE THEY
FEEL RACIALLY ISOLATED AND SO
THE NOTION OF A IT'S NOT ABOUT
RETENTION BUT REALLY TAKING
FULL ADVANTAGE. OF THE RICH
DIVERSITY THE FACULTY OF COLOR
BRING TO A CAMPUS IT IS TO THE
DETRIMENT OF THE COLLEGE NOT TO
ENSURE THAT FACULTY OF COLOR-
FEEL WELCOME SUPPORTED VERSUS
FEELING REYES. ISOLATED I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE A POINT. IN THAT
IS THE RESEARCH SHOWS THAT AT
LEAST THE ONE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
THAT THE RATE THE RACIAL
STUDENT EQUITY GAP NARAL BY
NINETEEN TO FIFTY ONE PERCENT.
BUT WHAT DOES THAT MEAN. THAT
MEANS THERE'S ABOUT ANOTHER
HALF. THAT DOES NOT AT THE GAP
HAS NOT CLOSE SO WHAT THAT
MEANS IS THE BURDEN OF RACIAL
EQUITY AND CLOSING THE RACIAL
EQUITY GAFFER STUDENTS SHOULD
NOT BE BASED ENTIRELY. ON
FACULTY OF COLOR THEY ARE
DEFINITELY OF CRITICAL STRATEGY
BUT IT IS FOR ALL FACULTY NO
MATTER WHAT RACE THAT THEY MUST
BE ENGAGED AROUND THE ISSUE OF
STUDENT ACTIVITY AND AROUND
CULTURAL RESPONSIVENESS. AND
AROUND IMPLICIT BIAS TOWARD
EACH OTHER AND TOWARD STUDENTS
SO IT IS THE RESPONSIBILITY. OF
ALL NOT JUST FOR FACULTY OF
COLOR. THE FIGURES THAT- WE
HAVE IN FRONT OF US THAT THE
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY- HAS
PROVIDED. AND THANK YOU FOR
THAT WORK- LOOKING AT NON
TENURED FACULTY. I THINK I AM
SURPRISED. THAT A THE LAST
DIVERSITY WITH PART TIME
FACULTY PURSES FULL TIME
FACULTY. I AND I AND I WONDER
IF OTHERS YOU KNOW MAY HAVE
BEEN SURPRISED AS I AM BECAUSE
IT WOULD SEEM LIKE THE POOL.
THAT WE'RE DRYING FROM FOR PART
TIME FACULTY. CERTAINLY SEEMS
TO BE MUCH BETTER. THEN THEN
THE POOL FOR FULL TIME FACULTY
SO IF BOTH OF YOU EITHER OF YOU
MIGHT WANT TO ADDRESS WHY WHY
DO YOU THINK THAT IS WHY WHY IS
THE PART TIME FACULTY NUMBERS.
ACTUALLY YES ACTUALLY SMALLER
LESS DIVERSE THAN THE FULL TIME
FACULTY. WELL YOU KNOW I THINK
IT IS CERTAINLY SURPRISING FOR
US WHEN WE WERE DOING THE
RESEARCH WE WERE TOLD BY
SEVERAL. SEVERAL FACULTY ON
CAMPUSES THAT WE NEEDED. YOU
KNOW TAKE OUT TENURE TO NON
TENURED- BECAUSE FACULTY WERE
SAYING THAT IN FACT THE NON
TENURED WERE LESS DIVERSE AND
YET THE ARGUMENT WAS ALWAYS
THIS IS A PIPELINE ISSUE RIGHT-
AND SO THE PIPELINE WILL GET
MORE DIVERSE IF WE JUST WAIT
LONG ENOUGH- AND SO I DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE ANSWER IS I THINK
YOU KNOW I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO
HEAR FROM OTHER FOLKS ON
CAMPUSES THAT MIGHT BE ABLE TO
SPEAK TO IT BETTER. BUT I WOULD
SAY THAT CLEARLY THERE IS-
BROKE IN HIRING AND VETTING
PROCESS THAT ISN'T BEING
INTENTIONAL ABOUT DIVERSITY AND
EQUITY IN A WAY THAT WOULD
PRODUCE DIFFERENT NUMBERS ONE
OF THE THINGS IN THE REPORT
THAT WE TALK ABOUT BECAUSE OF A
THE OTHER ARGUMENT IT'S OFTEN
MADE AS WELL THERE ARE FEWER
LET NEXT AND AFRICAN AMERICAN
AND FOLKS WITH. YOU KNOW.
ADVANCED DEGREES SO THE POOL IS
SMALLER AND WHAT WE FIND IS
WELL THE YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA'S
PRODUCING A LOT OF GRADUATES
THAT ARE. PEOPLE OF COLOR AND
SO THAT EXCUSE DOESN'T HOLD
VERY WELL AND IN THE UC WE SAY
YOU SEE HAS A STUDENT BODY.
WHERE THE LARGEST ETHNIC GROUP
IS ASIAN AMERICAN AND YET THEY
HAVE- A HUGE GAP IN
REPRESENTATION AMONGST FACULTY
FOR THEIR STUDENTS- AND WE ARE
PRODUCING. A LOT OF ASIAN
AMERICAN GRADUATES SO THE
ARGUMENT DOESN'T HOLD IF YOUR
SYSTEM IS BROKEN. IF YOUR
SYSTEM DOESN'T CARE ABOUT
DIVERSITY AN ACT IN A VERY REAL
AN INTENTIONAL WAY IT'S GOING
TO CONTINUE TO REPRODUCE. THESE
HIRING COMMITTEES ARE LOOKING
FOR PEOPLE THAT. YOU KNOW- LOOK
LIKE THEM. OFTENTIMES IN TERMS
OF WHAT THEY VALUE AS
EXPERIENCE WITH THE VALUE AS-
YOU KNOW QUALITY RESEARCH IF
THAT'S THE CASE FOR YOU SEE
PROFESSOR EXCITER. I FIVE EIGHT
A FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO THE CAMPAIGN AND TO THE
AIR FOR FOCUSING ON THE PART
TIME FACULTY AS I MENTIONED
THIS IS A RAPIDLY. A REALLY
CRITICAL AREA FOR A STUDENT
THEY MAKE NO DISTINCTION
BETWEEN A PART TIME AND FULL
TIME FACULTY YOU'RE MY FACULTY.
AND SO OF FROM A STUDENT
PERSPECTIVE WE GOT TO GET THIS
RIGHT- I CAN TAKE SO MUCH IN
THIS AREA BUT I'M GOING TO
LEAVE IT WITH ONE BIG PICTURE.
PART TIME FACULTY HIGHER IS
VERY FORMAL. MORE SO THAN FULL
TIME FACULTY HIGHER. OF FULL
TIME FACULTY HIGHER THE
TRAINING THERE'S A COMMITTEE OF
THEIR MUCH MORE FORMALITY IN
THE HIRING THE FULL TIME
FACULTY. VERSUS PART TIME
FACULTY. AND WHEN YOU HAVE AN
INFORMAL PROCESS SEES ARE OUT
OF COLLEGE- AROUND TOP PART
TIME FACULTY HIRE ANY SPECIALLY
THE PRESSURE POINTS OF QUICKLY
FINDING. OF PART TIME FACULTY
TO FILL ESPECIALLY IN CERTAIN
AREAS DOCKS WHERE MUCH OF THE
ISSUE OF EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY COMES INTO PLAY
SOME JUST GOING TO LEAVE IT AT
THAT THERE'S. SO MUCH TO UNPACK
AROUND THE TIME FACULTY HIRING.
THANK YOU I TOOK ON THINGS THAT
THE STATE CAN DO- COMMITMENT
SETTING GOALS- COMMITTEE
RESOURCES- INVESTMENT A DATA.
AND THE NUMBER FOUR DOWN I
THINK WHAT YOU'RE SPEAKING
ABOUT- THE PROCESS MASSES OF
HIGHER HUMAN RESOURCES THE
QUESTIONS THAT. AND AN EIGHT
ONE UPS SAID ON THAT ONE FOR A
LITTLE BIT. AS IT AS IT IS YOU
KNOW MY WIFE IS A HUMAN
RESOURCE MANAGER. WORKED FOR A
FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED COMPANY
FOR MANY YEARS. AND AS WE SPOKE
BEFORE THIS- HEARING THIS
MORNING AS WE SPOKE YESTERDAY.
I REALLY FEEL THAT PRIVATE
ENTERPRISE THE PRIVATE
COMPANIES HAVE DONE MUCH BETTER
THAN WE ARE DOING AS A STATE AS
WE ARE DOING IN THE THREE
SYSTEMS. AND SO IT MAKES ME
WONDER
HEAR YOU KNOW DESCRIPTION ABOUT.
THE BIAS AND I BELIEVE THAT
THEY- THE VERY TRUE AND WANTED
TO ALLEVIATE THAT AGAIN I AM
ROOM THE FIRST HEARING THAT WE
HAD. HEARD FROM AN AFRICAN
AMERICAN. AFRICAN AMERICAN
PROFESSOR I BELIEVE IN
ASTRONOMY FROM BERKELEY WOULD
BEEN THERE MANY YEARS. AND HE
SAID WE DO NOT HAVE A MORE.
FACULTY BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT
TO AND THAT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT I HEAR DISCUSSED ABOUT
INFORMALITY OF THE- HIGH TIMES
HIGHER. OF YOU KNOW THE
COMMITTEES THAT ARE. DO WORRY
ME QUITE A BIT AND HERE WE ARE
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. I MEAN.
ALL OF THE CIVIL RIGHTS. STRUCK
AND STILL. THE DATA YOU KNOW
FIFTY NINE PERCENT STUDENTS OF
COLOR. YOU KNOW MAYBE 20%
FACULTY OF COLOR. WE HAVE TO DO
BETTER WE HAVE TO DO BETTER FOR
ALL THE REASONS THAT YOU SAID
YOU KNOW FOR THE SUCCESS OF OUR
STUDENTS FOR THE- REST OF THE.
HOPE THAT IN THIS CONTINUE. YOU
CAN DO THAT. ANYTHING ELSE
YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE IN CLOSING.
I JUST REALLY QUICKLY. YOUR
WIFE AND IN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
I DON'T WANT COMPLETELY LOST IT
TOO MUCH THE PRIVATE SECTOR BUT
IT IS TRUE THEY ARE. SIX RATHER
MORE SOPHISTICATED. MANY OF THE
GOOD COMPANIES NOW DOING BLIND-
TO LOWER IMPLICIT BIAS THE BUT
THE REDACT OUT AND HAVE
SOFTWARE SYSTEMS TO DO SO IT'S
SOMETHING MAYBE WE SHOULD. FOR
IN THE TV COLLEGES AROUND THE
SYSTEM UP. GETTING
SOPHISTICATED MANY OF THEM IS
BECAUSE- MACKENZIE REPORT A 35%
INCREASE IN REVENUE TO THEIR
BOTTOM LINE AND SO THEY KNOW
THAT THIS IS SMART FOR BUSINESS
AND I THINK AS LONG AS WE STAY
FOCUSED ON THIS IS SMART FOR
STUDENTS THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
YOU'RE RIGHT. THANK YOU THANK.
FOR A JOINT TODAY YOUR SURE AND.
OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
WANTING TO DO THAT BY THIS
ISSUE SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU BOTH. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION I KNOW
THAT YOU MAY HAVE. YOUR CAMPUS.
FOR PATIENTS TODAY. SO OUR
SECOND PANEL WHAT HAS THE
SYSTEM ACCOMPLISH SINCE THE
HEARING OF OCTOBER TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN. AND AT THIS TIME WE
WILL TRANSITION WE WILL FOCUS
ON A SYSTEM WIDE AVERAGE OF
IMPROVING FACULTY DIVERSITY I
PARTICULARLY INTERESTED IN
HEARING AN UPDATE RE HOW THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE USE THE TWO DOLLARS.
MAJOR OKAY FACULTY AND WITH
THAT WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME
DAISY DR DAYS AGO ALICE DEPUTY
CHANCELLOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CANCERS.
WELCOME DOCTOR GONZALEZ. GOOD
MORNING TERM ENOUGH MORE
MORNING ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
COMMITTEE STAFF- COLLEAGUES AND
STUDENTS IN THE AUDIENCE AND
WERE WATCHING. I'M HERE WITH
GREAT HUMILITY AND PRIDE MY
STATE I SIT HERE AS THE SECOND
WOMAN AND THE FIRST PERSON OF
COLOR TO SERVE AS DEPUTY
CHANCELLOR OF OUR SYSTEM
OFFICE. NIGHT WHEN THE CYST
AFTER LEAVING THE STATE
LEGISLATURE SPECIFICALLY WE
OPERATIONS COMMITTEE I MEAN
I'VE BEEN AT THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE FOR TWO YEARS. SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
INVITATION TO SHARE WITH YOU.
AN UPDATE ON THE DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION TASK FORCE. ARE THAT
WAS ESTABLISHED BY THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS ON NOVEMBER TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN. ON
BEHALF OF CANCER OAKLEY I WANT
TO BEGIN BY THANKING ALL OF OUR
STATE WHAT STATE HER PARTNERS
WHO HIGHER HAVE BEEN IN. TOLL
SETTING PRESS. OF INSTITUTIONS
IT IS NOT EASY WORK AND
EVERYONE HAS A ROLE TO PLAY. I
WANT TO BEGIN BY THINKING THAT
FOR COLLEGE UNITY FOR THEIR
REPORT. NUMBER TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN THE PART OF THE REPORT
BOARD OF GOVERNORS. AND IT WAS
THAT REPORT THAT INSPIRED OR
BOARD TO TAKE ACTION- IN THE
WAY THAT WE HAVE AND THAT WILL
SHARE A LITTLE BIT. ABOUT I
SPECIFICALLY THE- JOHN STAND. I
HIM HE JOIN ME AS THE CO CHAIR
OF THE DIVERSITY EQUITY
INCLUSION TASK FORCE NEARLY TWO
MONTHS AGO. AND THEN OF COURSE
IT I THINK ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS. WHO SENT
REPRESENTATIVES FROM AFRO. I'M
AS WELL AS LEAGUE CEOS INTEREST
THESE AND YOU HAVE ONE OF THEM
IN YOUR PANEL LATER ON TODAY
DOCTOR MIGHT FORGET SCEA.
FOLLOWING ALONG ON TIME USE THE
POWER POINT AND I AM ON. I WANT
TO BEGIN FIRST BY SAYING A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE WORK THAT
WE'VE DONE SINCE THAT TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX NO PORTION.
THE FUNDING THAT WAS PROVIDED
TO OUR OFFICE WAS PROVIDED TO
DISTRICTS. SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER DAY. SEVENTY THREE
DISTRICTS ARE AT THE TIME
SEVENTY TWO DISTRICTS. IN
ADDITION TO THAT. JUST TO
ALLOWED OUR OFFICE TO USE 25%
OF IT TO OPERATE WHAT WE OF THE
CCC REGISTRY. WITH WEBSITE
OPERATE. WHERE ARE JOB POSTINGS
ARE PROVIDED THAT IS WHERE MOST
RECRUITMENT CAN HAPPEN. SINCE
THAT TIME WE ALSO. IS THE FUN
PART UNDERSTAND THEIR LOT.
INFORMATION INFORMATION IS AN
INSIDE AND AN INSIGHT BECOMES
AN ACTION SO WE DID STATEWIDE
WORKSHOPS ALL AROUND THE STATE
AND THE- PACIFIC. WE SET OUT TO
REALLY RECREATED IN. STOP AND
THAT IS THE WORK OF THE
DIVERSITY EQUITY INCLUSION TASK
FORCE AND I WOULD LIKE TO.
PHONE YOU ABOUT THAT WORK. TELL
YOU THAT INITIALLY WORK BEGAN
OUR BOARD OF GOVERNORS WANTED
US TO SET A VERY SPECIFIC GOAL
AMERICAL GOAL IS ATTACHED TO
THE VISION FOR SUCCESS. GETTING
IT FROM THE SYSTEM FOR MORE
LAWYERS. FROM MAKING A GOAL.
ULTIMATELY INTEGRATING
DIVERSITY EQUITY INCLUSION INTO
EVERYTHING THAT WE DO- AND THAT
WAS ONLY DONE AFTER WE ANALYZE
YES WHAT PRIVATE WORK SITES HAD
DONE AS WELL AS WORTH IT AND IN
OTHER SEGMENTS IN STATE AND
LOOKING AT OTHER BEING TO. THE
ONE IN YOUR- SET OUT TO. A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT. IN
ADDITION TO THAT. STATEWIDE
STRUCTURAL CHANGES WERE THIS IS
ABOUT. CHANGE PLEASE WAIT WHAT
POLICIES WHAT IS WHAT DO WE
NEED TO CHANGE AND NOT IS
WHAT'S IN FRONT OF YOU ON THIS
OUR POINT. I THINK IT'S AN FOR
TO LOOK AT THIS WITH A
HISTORICAL CONTEXT AND YOU
HEARD A LOT ABOUT POSITION.
NINE TWO THOUSAND AND- LET. TOO
MANY OF OUR DISTRICTS IN
COLLEGES WERE VERY VIEWS THEY
BELIEVE THAT PROP TWO OH NINE
ELIMINATED THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF COLLEGES AND DISTRICTS. AN
EQUAL EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITY
AND WHAT WE SAW A DEEP CONCERN
FROM THE CONSULTATION. AND
THEIR QUEST THE DOT A TASK
FORCE BE CREATED. THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THAT OUR SYSTEM HAS
DONE THIS. INTO WE SET OUT TO
REALLY RIGHT. EXPECTATIONS IN
THE RESPONSIBLE FOR DISTRICTS
AND WHAT HAPPENED WAS THAT MANY
OF OUR DISTRICTS BELIEVE THAT
FACULTY DIVERSITY INTERNSHIPS
WERE LEGAL THAT IS SIMPLY NOT
TRUE WHEN IN FACT THAT IS
ENCOURAGED BY THAT YOU'LL FUNDS
OF THE LEGISLATURE. BY THEY
ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE- TARGETED
OUT REACH ALSO SIMPLY NOT TRUE
THAT IS A BEST PRACTICE THAT IS
ENCOURAGED BY THE EAGLE PLANTS
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME AS A
SYSTEM TRYING TO RECTIFY.
PROVIDE INFORMATION PLANS ONLY
DOES. FROM STATEWIDE OFFICE BUT
THE WORK THAT WE ARE ENGAGED IN
TODAY IS WE'VE SEEN A PROGRESS
RIGHT WHEN YOU THROW MONEY AT
THE SITUATION AND WE WERE
PROVIDED TWO POINT TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN WE. START UP TAKE THERE
WERE SEVENTY SEVEN SEVEN.
MEETING EVIL PLANS WE JUMP
NINETY SIX PER IN A SINGLE YEAR.
96% OF A AND DOES NOT GET US AT
DIVERSITY WORK WRITER
DIVERSIFYING OUR FACULTY THAT
IS SIMPLY CHECKING OFF BOXES ON
AN EAGLE PLAN THAT IS SUBMIT
IT. THE REAL WORK HAPPENS AT
OUR COLLEGES AND- SO ON SLIDE
THREE. THE REAL WORK THAT TOOK
PLACE OVER THE LAST TEN MONTHS.
OUR WHEN WE BEGAN THIS JOURNEY
WE KNEW THAT WE NEEDED TO
INTEGRATE THIS WORK INTO THE
VISION FOR SUCCESS OUR VISION
FOR SUCCESS IS OUR STRATEGIC.
IN OUR THAT ADDRESSES STUDENT
COMPLETE INS FOR BERMAN EQUITY
AT. CLEARLY SPECIFICALLY OUR
BOARD HAS ASKED US TO INTEGRATE
IT INTO LOCAL RULES AND AS A
TASK FORCE WE DECIDED THAT THIS
WORK THE WORK OF DIVERSIFYING
OUR FACULTY. FALL WITHIN VISION
FOR SUCCESS GOING FIVE TO
REDUCE AND REYES EQUITY GAPS IN
OUR SYSTEM. AND IT FALLS UNDER
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR
COMMITMENTS. WE SAY IS ON
STUDENTS AND GOALS THAT IS
WITHIN THEIR RIGHT WHEN WE SAY
DESIGN. IN MIND THE WORSE THE
FINER FACULTY IS HOW WE GET
THERE. YOU KNOW WITH EVERY
CONVERSATION TASK FORCE ON
FLIGHT NUMBER FOUR. EVERYTHING
BEGINS WITH DATA. AND I HAVE TO
TELL YOU AS A RECOVERING
RESEARCHER- DATA STEP ONE
BECAUSE SOMETIMES IT'S OUR NEED
TO ASK FOR MORE INFORMATION AS
A TASK FORCE WHAT WE DECIDED
WAS THAT WE AGREE ON A FEW NOT
ONLY DID SIT DOWN LOOKED AT.
LEAST THE STORE HUMANS OF OUR.
TO LEARN. IS BY TRAINING A WE
HAD IN. A MINUTE THE DOW WITH
OUR TASK FORCE TO LOOK ABOUT WE
LOOKED AT CULTURAL COMPETENCY-
AND THEN WE HAD A PANEL OF
FACULTY OF COLOR. WHO WE HEARD
FROM AND THEY TAUGHT US ABOUT
WHAT IT WILL TAKE TO DO TENSION
AND SO ARE AND HOW WE SUPPORT
FORTY OF COLOR. AND HERE'S WHAT
WE ENDED UP WITH IN TERMS OF
THE DATA THAT RECOGNIZED
BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT TO WE
THAT CONCEPT TO MOVE FORWARD
TOGETHER HAS A SYSTEM. THE
FIRST. ARM ROMAN IS ACTUALLY
SLIGHTLY UP AND THAT. IS ARE
GETTING MORE DIVERSE. FLIGHT
NUMBER FIVE WE HAVE THE MOST
DIVERSE STUDENT POPULATION OF
ALL SYSTEMS OF PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION AND IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT CAMPUS YOU STEP FOOT ON
THAT ANY ANY COLLEGE CAMPUS.
RENTS ARE THE MOST DIVERSE
GROUP ON THAT CAN. AND LASTLY
WE AGREED TO DIVERSIFICATION IS
A NATIONAL PROBLEM. ON SLIDE
NUMBER SIX YOU SEE THE
INFORMATION THAT WAS ALREADY
ALREADY PROVIDED FROM THE
EARLIER PANEL THAT IN FACT WE
SEE MANY DIFFERENCES INCLUDING
THE FACT THAT OUR JOB COOL T.
R. EVEN A STATE PERSON OUR-
FACULTY. AND THEN SLIDE NUMBER
SEVEN THIS WHERE WE. DATA
DOESN'T CHANGE PEOPLE TO. IT
TOOK US FOUR MONTHS TO GET TO
THIS POINT BUT THIS IS WHY THIS
IS SO IMPORTANT FOR OUR SYSTEM
WE NEED MORE DATA BECAUSE
MATTER HOW YOU SLICE IT SAID
THIS WILL BURKE IS ABOUT
TRANSFORMING IT. TO SHOW
QUILTERS. AS A SYSTEM WE NEED
TO MOVE FOR PASSED I AIMS TO
EMPOWER MEANT AND WHAT I MEAN
BY THAT IS THAT OUR SYSTEM.
NEEDS TO ADDRESS THE POLICIES
AND REGULATE MEANS THE
PROCEDURES FORMAL ACTICIN EVEN
THOSE MISCONCEPTIONS THAT WE
HAVE ABOUT WHAT. TO DO OR NOT.
IN ORDER TO THEN IMPACT BILL.
USE BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT. AND I'M
NOT NEXT LET ME SEE THAT THESE
ARE THE COURAGEOUS PEOPLE WHO
JOB DOES FOR TEN MONTHS LEAVE
THIS WORK FOR OUR SYSTEM. AND
OUR TASK. BY THE COLD THE
PRESIDENT OF THE STATEWIDE
ACADEMIC SENATE DOCTOR JOHN
STANCE GIVES. ON SLIDE NUMBER
NINE ARE YOU A BRIEF HISTORY OF
OUR JOURNEY YOU SEE ON HERE
THAT WE BEGAN WITH SIX MONTHS
OF ENGAGEMENT AND THIS CRITIC
NEW HAD MEANT. THAT INTO AN AND
THEN TRY THIS RIGHT WE TRIED A
TASK FORCE WE TRY CREATING PLAN
AND THE PLAN IS THE EASY PART
WHAT IS WHAT WAS DIFFERENT
ABOUT THAT WE NEEDED TO. FIND
PROBLEM ENTIRE THEM IN ORDER TO
BE. BECAUSE AS WE MOVE FORWARD
WITH THIS WORK. AND WE DID THAT
FOR SIX MONTHS WE PRESENT AT
STATEWIDE CONFERENCES. AND ON
SITE NUMBER TEN THIS IS WHAT WE
SHARED WITH THE SYSTEM. WE
SHARED WITH THE SYSTEM ON
SEPTEMBER SEVENTEENTH ON THIS
CAMPUS MUST BE SOMETHING IN THE
WATER IN THE AIR- BUT HE WAS
APPROVED UNANIMOUSLY BY THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS ON THAT DAY.
AND WHAT WE COULD ALL AGREE.
THAT EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES ARE REQUIRED BY
THE LAW. IT IS MEANT TO HELP US
BE RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF
THE OF OUR DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATION. THAT THIS WORK IS
EVER FOR STUDENT OUTCOMES AN
EDUCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENT AND
VERY IMPORTANTLY THAT THIS WORK
WILL HELP US CLOSE EQUITY APPS
IF WE ARE TRULY COMMITTED TO
THIS WORK. WE ARE FIRM THIS
WORK ON SLIDE NUMBER ELEVEN-
WHERE WE TALKED ABOUT. FACULTY
DIVERSIFICATION AS IMMOBILIZER
FOR SOCIAL MOBILITY AND STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT AND AS A SYSTEM
AGREED THAT WE NEED TO MOVE
PAST COMPLIANCE RIGHT AND FOCUS
REALLY ON THOSE PARTNERSHIPS
THAT NEED TO TAKE PLACE AT
DISTRICTS DEPARTMENTS VISIONS.
IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT SOMETHING
LIKE THAT. PETER DISTRICTS IN
OUR COLLEGES TO PARTNER UP TO
DO THE WORK. IT'S LIKE TWELVE
YOU THAT WORK VISUALLY AND THE-
CHANGE THAT WE ALL AGREED ON AS
A SYSTEM AS A TASK FORCE. STATE
IS REALLY THE THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT I WOULD
LIKE TO ONLY BRIEFLY TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT- THIS IS THE
WORK THAT WE'RE CURRENTLY
ENGAGED IN. ON SLIDE FOURTEEN
THE BOARD OF GOVERNORS VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY ON THESE THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT FIRST
RECOMMENDATION IS ACTUALLY A
SIXTEEN PAGE REPORT OF
STRATEGIES TO CHANGE
REGULATIONS PROCEDURES AND SENT
SOME BEST PRACTICES. I THINK A
KEY PART OF THE WORD IS YOU
KNOW A LOT ABOUT A ROOM OF. HIS
IN RESOURCE ARE NEEDED BUT A
LOT OF WORK IS ALSO WE CAN. ONE
OF THE LEVERS TO DO THIS WORK
AND HOW IT'S A COMPLIANCE LEVER
BUT OUR TASK FORCE ALSO
IDENTIFIED DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT CAN BE DONE ON ON THOSE
SIXTEEN PAGES. THE FIRST IS A
TIER ONE ACT HE WHICH- CAN BE
DONE EXISTING. SO MEANING DONE.
SO I PROVIDE YOU TO REALLY
BRIEF EXAMPLES BUT THE ONE I
WANT TO FOCUS ON IS SLIDE
NUMBER SEVENTEEN. SO THE VISION
FOR SUCCESS HAS SEVEN
COMMITMENTS AND ONE OF THOSE
COMMITMENTS IS COMMITMENT
NUMBER THREE. I EXPECTATIONS
SUPPORT. WHAT ARE TASK DECIDED
WAS THAT ONE OF THE STRATEGIES
IN WHICH WE CAN PAYER HIGH
EXPECTATIONS WITH HIGH SUPPORT
IS TO ESTABLISH A PIPELINE
PROGRAM TODAY THE FIRE FACULTY
APPLICANT POOL THIS IS ONE OF
THE WAYS IN WHICH IN BOTH IN
PRIVATE OF THE QUIRK LIGHTS HOW
THAT WOULD. WORK HAS BEEN DONE
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD. TO POST
IT'S ONE OF THOSE EXIT. IN OUR
SYSTEM WE IDENTIFY TIER ONE
THESE AS A WAY TO MOBILIZE AND
TO CREATE THAT FACULTY
APPLICANT POOL AND DIVERSIFY
THE APPLICANT POOL. ONE OF THEM
EXCITED IN THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE HAVE AGREED TO PARTNER
TO PROVIDE STATEWIDE GUIDANCE
CLARITY. NEWMAN QUALIFICATIONS
OF TACKLE T. AND I'M SURE THE
MIX AND IT WILL SPEAK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THIS LATER. A
LOT OF CONCEPTION OUR SYSTEM
ABOUT WHAT IS REQUIRED VERSES
WHAT IS PREFERRED IF YOU TITLE
FIVE THERE WE TO MINIMUM POLICY
IS FOR FACULTY. SO WE BELIEVE
THAT BY A TV. ONE SEVENTY
NUMBER ONE YOU SEE ON HERE THAT
WE CAN BEGIN TO CHIP AWAY. TO
CLARIFY THAT FOR SYSTEM. TV IS
TO CREATE A STATEWIDE PILOT
FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM TO HELP
ENCOURAGE YOUR STUDENTS TO COME
BACK TO OUR COLLEGES AND TEACH
IF THEY ARE IN FACT THE MOST
DIVERSE. SEGMENT OF OUR
COLLEGES WHY NOT FIGURE OUT HOW
TO LET THEM COME BACK IN
TEACHER CAMPUSES AND WE HAVE
SEEN HUGE MOVEMENT ARE
HISTORICALLY BLACK COLLEGES AND
GRADUATE GRAD FROM PROGRAM THAT
ARE COMING BACK TO OUR STATE
WITH MASTER DEGREES SO I THINK
EIGHTY EIGHT YEARS. CAPTURE
THOSE STUDENTS. COMING BACK.
ABOUT TRANSFORMING THE
STRUCTURE. PROCEEDS TO THEN
IMPACT THE PRACTICES ARE THIS
ONE SPECIFICALLY CAME UP
THROUGH OUR MANY DISCUSSIONS
ACROSS OUR STATE AND
CONVERSATIONS WITH MANY
DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS WITHIN
THE TASK FORCE. THE CLEAR
DEFINITION FOR DIVERT. WE
ACTUALLY DIDN'T HAVE ONE WE HAD
A VERY GENERIC- LANGUAGE THAT
IS ACTUALLY BEEN TITLE FIVE THE
RIVER CITY MEANS A CONDITION OF
BROAD INCLUSION. IN AN
ENVIRONMENT IN AN ENVIRONMENT
THAT OFFERS EQUAL EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL PERSONS
REQUIRES BOTH THE PRESENCE ON
THE RESPECTFUL TREATMENT OF
INDIVIDUALS. OUR COLLEGES AND
DISTRICT ASK FOR GUIDANCE AND
SO RECOMMENDATION NUMBER TWO IS
ACT WAS ACTUALLY THE ADOPTION
OF A DIVERSITY ECCRINE
INCLUSIONS MEANT SO WHAT ARE
VALUES BELIEFS AS A SYSTEM. AND
THEN HOW CAN WE USE THE
LANGUAGE THAT WAS ADOPTED TO
ANTI. SO THAT WOULD LET ME BE A
SOMETHING THAT WOULD REPORT TO
ALL OF YOU TO THAN HELP US
WITH- HOW WE CHANGE THE XIN
STATEMENT ON THE STUMP. AS WELL
AS CHANGING THE EGO. CHANGING
THE TEMPLATE AS WELL AS
CHANGING THE MORE FOR MEASURES
WHICH IS THE WAY THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE FUNDS ARE EAGLE
PLANS ALL OF THOSE CHANGES NEED
TO HAPPEN. IN ORDER FOR US TO
REALLY HAVE A DEFINITION IN A
STATEMENT WERE EQUITY DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION ARE AT THE
FOREFRONT- IN A- RISE OUT ON
PAGE NINE ON SLIDE NINETEEN. I
SHOW YOU THAT VERY FIRST
PARAGRAPH OF THAT STATEMENT IT
WAS REALLY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
START WITH THE STUDENT IN MY-
THE FIRST SENTENCE IS WITH THE
GOAL OF ENSURING THAT.
OPPORTUNITY OF ALL STUDENTS
RIGHT WE WERE VERY INTENSE NO
AS A TASK FORCE TO BEGIN THEIR
TO REMIND EVERYONE THAT THIS
WORK. IS IN SERVICE OF OUR
STUDENTS. AND OUR LAST
RECOMMEND AND I'M ALMOST
TOWARDS THE END- IS IT WAS A
RECOMMENDED ADOPTION OF A
BUDGET REQUEST FOR THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS TO MOVE FORWARD TO
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
HISTORICALLY THE STATE HASN'T
VESTED ONE TIME FUNDS FOR FULL
TIME FACULTY HIRING TYPICALLY
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME.
THE TASK FORCE PROPOSED
INDICATED FUNDING MODEL THAT X.
INVESTMENT STOCK TO THE FIRST
TWO RECOMMENDATIONS AND THEY
ALSO REQUEST THE MOBILE FUND.
ON SLIDE TWENTY ONE LOOK YOU
CAN SEE SOME OF THE REQUESTED
FOR TO OUR BOARD OF GOVERNORS-
THAT WERE SUBMITTED THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU SEE A
LOT OF THOSE NEEDS ARE REALLY
AROUND THINGS UP THE FIRST
PANELIST SHARED OUR
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT KLAY
ON DATE. TIME HIRING DOT. I'M
IS THERE CONNECTED TO THIS
WORK. YOUR PLAN FUNDING IN
ORDER TO DO SOME OF THE BEST
PRACTICES SOME OF THESE IDEAS
THAT ARE ALREADY THERE ALREADY
INCENTIVIZE BY TITLE FIVE. THE
FUNDING HAS NOT BEEN THERE BUT
ALSO IT'S BECAUSE WE KEEP THESE
CONVERSATIONS I LOS RATE. A
STATEWIDE FACULTY FELLOWSHIP
YOU SEE THAT ON HERE A
MODERNIZE HE SEES REGISTRY
WEBSITE OUR WEBSITE IS
EXTREMELY OLD AND WHAT WE KEEP
HEARING ACROSS THE STATE IS.
THAT NOT ONLY DO WE NEED A
PLACE WHERE WE CAN UPLOAD ALL.
OF THERE AND USE DATA TO
ANALYZE. WHOSE ACTUALLY
APPLYING TO THESE JOBS WHAT'S
THE APPLICANT POOL THEY WOULD
LIKE A SITE THAT'S ABLE TO
AGGREGATE THAT DATA AND PROVIDE
THAT ANALYSIS. AND SO THAT
WOULD BE THE MODERNIZING OF
THAT WEBSITE ONLINE TRAINING
MODULES VERY IMPORTANT I THINK
WHAT YOU'RE SEEING ACROSS
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE WORK SITES
IS THAT IS NOT GOOD ENOUGH TO
JUST TO CULTURAL COMPETENCY ARE
ON. JUST AS FOR HIRING
COMMITTEE THAT INDIVIDUAL THEN
HAS TO THAT WORK AT THAT WORKS
STATE AND SO THE NEW PRACTICES
IN DOING THAT CAMPUS WIDE SO
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOME PRIVATE
CALL IS. ANOTHER STATE I'M CON
IS A CULTURAL COMPETENCY THE
RECALL. A SINGLE FRESHMAN THAT
IN AND I CAMPUS SO THE ONLINE
TRAINING MODULES WOULD BE OUR
OFFICE PROVIDING A MODEL A
MODEL ON A JEWEL. OF CAMPUSES.
CAN YOU. ONE OF OUR LAWYERS
WHO'S WHO ONE OF THREE LAWYERS
IN OUR SYSTEM OFFICE. I'LL END
WITH THIS WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
ONGOING WORK AND ON SLIDE
TWENTY TWO I SUMMARIZE SOME OF
THE REALLY BIG GOALS AND
TIMELINE PIECES THAT OUR OFFICE
NEEDS TO MEET FOR A BOARD OF
GOVERNORS. BUT THE FIRST TIME
WE PRESENT AT THIS A PROBLEM.
WE HAD FOLKS WHO WOULD LEAVE
THE ROOM WHEN WE WOULD HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION. WE'VE COME A
LONG WAY. I THINK YOU HAVE A
SYSTEM THAT IS READY TO HAVE
THIS CONVERSATION TO MAKE THE
CHANGES THAT ARE NEEDED. YOU
HAVE A BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
NEEDED AND YOU HAVE A CHANCE IS
OFFICE STAFF THAT'S DEDICATED
TO ENSURING THAT THIS WORK GETS
DONE. THANK YOU HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU. MISS
GARCIA. LIKE TO MAKE ANY
OPENING REMARKS OR. THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE HE IS VERY
FOR THE DELAY I LIKE HERE FOR
THE HEARING IN TWO THOUSAND.
SIXTEEN SO PRETTY THE BABY BACK
HERE TO HEAR THE OF. WHERE WE
ARE. IN THE. I AND IN THE
PROCESS OF PLANNING. I'M HAPPY
TO SEE WERE ÁP BUT I GUESS I
WISH YOU WERE A LITTLE FURTHER
AHEAD AND IMPLEMENTATION OF
SOME OF THE STUFF BUT I
UNDERSTAND THE NECESSITY TO
PLAN TO COLLECT THE DATA SO.
APPRECIATE HER BEING HERE AND
HER INSIGHT THANK YOU TO THIS
ISSUE AND I DID WANT TO THE
FROM THE PREVIOUS CONVERSATION
OR TALKING ABOUT YOU SEEM
PROGRAMS TO HELP US WITH THE
PRESS THE BIAS AND AT THE END
OF THE THIRD DEFINITELY TOOLS
BUT WE NEED TO BE AWARE. OF THE
LIMITATIONS TO HANDLE SCHOOLS
BECAUSE WHEN THEY'RE BEING
BUILT OUT THAT BY THIRTY IN
THEM A LOT OF NICE CORRECT ALL
OF IT. ALONG THE WAY AND SO WE
NEED TO BE AWARE THAT WHILE THE
LIMITATION DOESN'T CORRECT FOR
THE IMPLICIT BIAS BECAUSE OF
THE DISSENTERS. PEOPLE HAD A
VISIT BY THAT THE BUILDING INTO
A PROGRAM. DOCTOR DOLLARS I
LOOK LIKE THE SLIDE THAT I
THINK IT SAYS THAT THAT. PLANS
DON'T CHANGE PEOPLE. SOMETHING
LIKE THAT AND SO. COLLEGES THAT
HAVE MADE EACH AND THEN YOU YOU
YOU MENTIONED THAT THAT IT TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION SOME
PEOPLE USED TO LEAVE THE ROOM.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
SOME COLLEGES HAVE BEEN MORE
SUCCESSFUL THAN OTHERS. IN
DIVERSIFYING THEIR FACULTY. AND
UNDERSTAND THAT AT SOME OF THE
PLACES WHERE THAT IS HAPPENING
THERE ARE EXPERIENCING PUSH
BACK IF THAT A GOOD USE THAT
PHRASE. FROM FROM THE COLLEGES
THEMSELVES OR FROM FACULTY
THEMSELVES OF FROM EXISTING
FACULTY HOW WOULD YOU ADDRESS
THAT. NO I THERE IS THERE IS A
LOT OF I CAN TELL YOU IN IN
DOING THIS WORK- YOU KNOW IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO US TO FOCUS
ON YES THE PRE HIRING THE
HIRING BUT VERY IMPORTANT ON
THE RETENTION PIECE. RIGHT
THERE'S NOT ENOUGH- FUNDING
THAT YOU CAN PROVIDE A
DIFFERENCE UNLESS WE BEGIN TO
DO THE STRUCTURAL CHANGES AT
OUR CAMPUSES- WHAT I FOUND WAS
WANTED TO CREATE A PANEL. OF
FIVE COLOR. STORIES WITH UPS
THOUGHT WHAT WOULD TAKE TO
RETAIN THEM AND WHAT THEY GO
THROUGH. I FAILED I GETTING AN
INITIAL PANEL TO COME AND SPEAK
TO OUR TASK FORCE AND I HAD TO
ASK FOR HELP. AND EVERY SINGLE
PERSON HAD ASKED WAS AND I
DIDN'T REALIZE THAT THE TIME
WAS NOT TEN YEARS. AND SO WHAT
HAPPENED WAS THAT THEY SHARED
THAT THEY WERE NOT COMFORTABLE
WITH COMING UP IN SHARING THEIR
STORIES IN SACRAMENTO. AND SO I
ASKED FOR HELP AND EVENTUALLY
THE PANEL THAT WE GOT WERE
INCREDIBLE SENATE PRESIDENTS IN
OUR STATE WHO HAD TENURE. AND
WHO WERE WERE NOT A FREE
COURAGEOUS TO SHARE THEIR
STORIES WITH OUR TASK FORCE. I
THINK THAT WILL BE VERY COMMON
THAT'S THE WORK THAT WE'VE SEEN
IN PUBLIC AND PRIVATE WORK
SITES I THINK THOSE CAMPUSES
THAT ARE DOING REALLY WELL.
HAVE LEADERSHIP. AND I THINK
YOU HEARD THAT VERY CLEARLY
FROM THE FIRST PANEL
SPECIFICALLY. FROM TWENTY WHO
TALKED ABOUT HOW THIS WORK GETS
IMPLEMENTED. A PART OF OUR JOB
AT THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IS
TO CREATE THOSE. POLICIES THOSE
STRUCTURES RIGHT IN WHICH FOLKS
HAVE TO OPERATE UNDER BUT AT
THE LOCAL LEVEL IT COMES DOWN
TO LEADERSHIP AND I THINK
YOU'LL HEAR THAT CLEARLY VERY
LOUD. IN SOME OF THE OTHER
PANELISTS WERE COMING UP. TALK
ABOUT A CULTURAL. SHIFT IN THE
CULTURE. ESPECIALLY IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WERE WERE I
BELIEVE OF THE POOL. I THINK IT
IS A SHELVE STATED. COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY HAS SHOWN THE WE'VE
CERTAINLY GRADUATING A DIVERSE.
NUMBER OF THE STUDENTS AND WE
HAVE FOR MANY YEARS NOW- WITH
MASTERS AND NOT IN MANY MANY
AREAS- AND AMONG THOSE ARE OUR
STUDENTS OF COLOR RIGHT WHO ARE
COMING OUT WITH MASTER'S
DEGREES. BUT THEN. VERY OFTEN I
CONTINUE TO HEAR STORIES OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHO WHO.
WOULD GO BEYOND THE MASTERS AND
LOOK FOR THAN SOMEONE WITH THE
DOCTOR. WHICH TO ME MAKES NO
SENSE AT ALL. GIVEN THE
STUDENTS THAT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE TEACHING. FIFTY
NINE PERCENT- STUDENTS OF COLOR.
I'M NOT SURE THE NUMBERS I
DON'T HAVE IN FRONT OF ME HOW
MANY OF THEM YOU KNOW WE SAW
WE'RE NOT COLLEGE READY IN
ENGLISH AND MATH. I PERSONALLY
DON'T THINK THAT. YOU KNOW I
RESPECT ANY FACULTY WHO HAS A
PHD A RESPECTED OF THE WORK
THEY DID BUT CERTAINLY IT IS
NOT NECESSARY TO HAVE A PHD TO
TEACH AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
N. F. DEPARTMENTS. CONTINUE TO
OF. PHD TO A AN APPLICANT WITH
A MASTERS IN JUST IN DOING THAT
THEY ARE SELECTING OUT PERHAPS.
APPLICANTS WHO ARE RICH
APPLICANTS OF COLOR WHO COULD
BE VERY SUCCESSFUL IN TEACHING
I LIKE THE IDEA OF THE PIPELINE
I LIKE THE IDEA OF UNITY
COLLEGES SAYING WE ARE GOING TO
GET THE STUDENTS AND THAT WE'RE
GOING TO ASK THEM WE'RE GONNA
TRACK THEM THROUGH. GRADUATE. I
LIKE THAT CONCEPT BUT IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE TO ME THAT THE POOL
EXIST ALREADY. AND WE ARE CLOSE
ENOUGH. TO THOSE WHO ARE
ALREADY THERE ALREADY QUALIFIED
AND WE DO IT. ABSENT SUBTLE AND
NOT SO SUBTLE WAYS. SO. AND I
DO HEAR THAT I HEAR THAT FROM
APPLICANTS. I YOUR THAT QUITE A
BIT. RESPOND I THINK THERE ARE
TWO KEY AREAS AND DOCTOR JOHN
STANCES CAN BE A LOT MORE
ELOQUENT THAN I CAN TALK ABOUT-
EQUIVALENCY PROCESS SEES- AND
THE ROLE OF THE ACADEMIC SENATE
IN THAT WORK- BUT THE EXAMPLE
THAT I GAVE YOU GUYS WAS EASY
ABOUT WHAT IS REQUIRED VERSUS
PREFERRED. TITLE FIVE. I THINK
THAT THE FIRST BILL. FIRST IT'S
BEING IMPLEMENTED A HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN DIFFERENT WAYS- BUT AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS A PHD I WOULD
ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH YOU. JUST
BECAUSE YOU HAVE ONE DOESN'T
MEAN THAT YOU'RE THE RIGHT
PERSON TO TEACH OUR. WELL AND
MY IS IT IT'S ONLY. NOT A
PREREQUISITE FOR. AND COMMUNITY.
CONNECT QUESTION WHAT ARE YOU
TO MINIMUM YEAH SO THE FIRST
REQUIREMENT IS AN ACADEMIC
REQUIREMENT WHICH IS TYPICALLY
A MASTER'S DEGREE ON THE OTHER
ONE IS A SENSITIVITY TO AN
UNDERSTANDING OF THE DIVERSE
POPULATION OF OUR STUDENTS SO
HOW DO YOU QUANTIFY THAT SECOND
ONE THE MATHIS MCCARTY SO I
WILL TELL YOU WHAT KIND OF
DOESN'T SAY HAS ALSO IT DOESN'T
SAY IN ORDER FOR YOU TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT IS CURRENT
HAVE. TITLE FIVE DOES NOT SAY
THAT YOU ONLY. QUESTION IT IS
NOT A YES SIR. BERMAN HAS BEEN
IMPLEMENTED THROUGH A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS I THINK ONE- AS WE
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS WORK AND
WHAT THE ACADEMIC SENATE HAS
COMMITTED TO IS HOW DO WE BEGIN
TO SHOW GOOD MODELS TO OUR
COLLEGES AND DISTRICTS AND BEST
PRACTICES HOW YOU DO THAT. AND
WE WILL THE WAY THAT YOU DO
THAT IS NOT JUST BY ASKING HE
SERVED A DIVERSE STUDENT
POPULATION OR DO YOU HAVE A
SENSITIVITY IT'S WHAT HAVE BEEN
THE OUTCOMES OF THOSE STUDENTS
AND HOW HAVE YOU. CONTRIBUTED
TO THOSE OUTCOMES. SO. ALI IS
TALKING ABOUT WE I'VE
DEFINITELY I'VE I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE OF TEACHING AND THE
MIDDLE SCHOOL ALL THE WAY TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL AND
AT THE UNIVERSITY AND I'VE
DEFINITELY SEEN IT AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL WHERE
WE WILL GIVE SO WHAT THE PHD.
JOB. WALK INTO THE CLASSROOM
ONE THAT DOESN'T TRANSFER INTO
DOING. I'VE SEEN IT WITH
MASSIVE DOSES I WANT TO. HOW DO
WE DEAL WITH STUDENTS WHO ARE
COMING IN AND WE NEED TO
REMEDIATE WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE. AND AS A MATH. THE LOS
MATT THAT FIND THAT MOST I AM
THE MORE TRAINING AND EDUCATION
WE HAVE THE LEAST REPAIR WE ARE
TO DEAL WITH THE STUDENTS WHO
CAN'T RELATE TO THEM. EASY FOR
US. AND THE WAY WE HAVE TAUGHT
IT HAS WORKED FOR US ALWAYS.
BUT IT TURNS OUT THAT IT
DOESN'T WORK FOR THE MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE OUT THERE. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'RE GONNA GET
NECESSARILY ANNA. MASTERS CLASS
OR PHD CLASS. THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT SOMETIMES A SOME MORE
OFTEN IN THE HIGH SCHOOL
CREDENTIAL LEVEL WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT THOSE THINGS. AND THEN
THEY- ARE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
THINGS MORE. ARM OUR STUDENTS
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IT
MAKES NO SENSE TO ME. OUT THERE
SO I THINK. NOT ONLY. OUR
TALENTED BUT WE ALSO. IT'S ALL
OVER THE BY THAT THAT WE SEEM
TO THINK THAT THAT THE GREEN
LEADS TO BE IN A GOOD. ON IT'S
BEEN MY EXPERIENCE BUT IT'S
USUALLY THE OPPOSITE. ABS MY
LAST QUESTION. THE WORK OF THE
TASK FORCES AND I REALIZE
THERE'S A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
MY CORRECT DIFFERENT A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. YOU
KNOW I KNOW THE DATA. IS PRETTY
I WOULD I WOULD SAY DISMAL. HOW
DO YOU FEEL YOU KNOW THAT WE
CHANGED ANYTHING SINCE THE TWO
MILLION DOLLARS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PROVIDED. IS
READY FOR THE QUESTION I MADE A
LIST. I THINK THERE WERE THREE
THINGS THAT HAVE CHANGED SINCE
YOU PROVIDED THAT FUNDING I
THINK ONE AS YOU CONTINUE TO
HAVE THAT- YOU WILL CONTINUE TO
HOLD THEIR SYSTEM ACCOUNTABLE
SO IT'S A PART OF THAT THAT-
COME WHAT COMPELS PEOPLE TO
TAKE ACTION. I THINK THAT FIRST
PIECES REALLY IN IN CONTINUE TO
HIGHLIGHT THIS WHICH IS NOT YOU
WAS SAID BY THE EARLIER AND
ALL. I THINK THE OTHER PIECE IS
OP HIGHLIGHTING. PARTNERSHIPS
AND I THINK YOU'VE SEEN THAT IN
THIS WORK- OUR ACADEMIC SENATE
PARTNER WITH OUR OFFICE TO DO
THIS WORK AND THAT WILL BE
CRITICAL AND US BEING ABLE TO
SAID HE'D MOVING FORWARD. AND
THEN NOT BE ON. SEVERAL
DIFFERENT PIECES OF THIS
REQUIRE. FIVE CHANGES DIFFERENT
REGULATION CHANGE. EXPO IN A
SPACE LIKE THIS IN PICKING
THROUGH HOW WE THEN MOBILIZE AN
ENTIRE SYSTEM HAS BEEN A PART
OF THE PROGRESS RIGHT I THINK.
WE CONTINUE TO OPERATE WITHIN
EXISTING POLICIES INSTRUCTORS
WHAT PRINT AND WHERE WE ARE
EIGHT IS THAT WERE SEEN THAT
THOSE STRUCTURES NO LONGER WORK
AND THAT THEY WILL NOT GET US
TO WHERE WE NEED TO BE. OUT
ABOUT IMPLEMENTING THIS TWELVE.
WELL THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE I
AM VERY HAPPY THAT YOU ARE. THE
COMMUNITY SYSTEM AT LOOKS TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TOGETHER THANK
YOU. AND WITH THAT WE WILL
TRANSITION TO OUR THIRD PANEL
WHICH WILL FOCUS ON CAMPUS
EFFORTS OF IMPROVING FACULTY
DIVERSITY AND I'D LIKE TO
INVITE FORWARD PRESIDENT OF
IMPERIAL VALLEY COLLEGE. MORE
THE GARCIA. THE PRESIDENT OF
THE ACADEMIC SENATE FROM
IMPERIAL ABOUT VALLEY COLLEGE
MERRY LOFGREN. PRESIDENT OF SAN
JOSE CITY COLLEGE ROLAND MONTEL
MY YOUR- AND THE COUNSELOR
COORDINATOR OF EXTENDED YOUR P.
SERVICES FROM SAN JOSE CITY
COLLEGE BOB YOU GONZALEZ AS
WELL AS THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
ACADEMIC AFFAIRS FOR RCC. FAR
WELCOME ALL. AND I'M NOT SURE
IN WHAT ORDER. IF YOU'VE
ALREADY DETERMINED THAT. VERY
GOOD THAT WE CALLED YOU A GREAT.
WELCOME. GOOD MORNING TERM
MEDINA ASSEMBLY WOMAN GARCIA
COMMITTEE STAFF MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IT IS AN
HONOR TO BE HERE THIS MORNING
VIEW ALL AND I WAS A MEMBER
GARCIA SENDS HIS REGARDS. THANK
YOU. I SPOKE TO HIM OF THIS
WORK FOR THE WEEKEND SO YES HE
HE. CONSIDERED BEING HERE BUT
WAS NOT ABLE TO. SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU WHOLE HEARTEDLY FOR
YOUR FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO. IT
AND SUCCESS SPECIFICALLY THE
SUCCESS OF OUR MINORITY
STUDENTS WHICH COMPRISE THE
MAJORITY OF OUR STUDENTS AND AS
PREVIOUSLY STATED AND AS
RESEARCH INDICATES SUCH AS
STENCILS WORKMEN SIMONE'S WORK-
DR HARRISON DOCTOR WAIT FROM
SAN DIEGO STATE. IF WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT AS THE SYSTEM WE
ENHANCE STUDENT SUCCESS.
DIVERSE CITY MATTERS. AND IT'S
REFLECTED IN THE SYSTEM AS- IN
OUR STUDENTS CENTERED FUNDING
FORMULA WE HAVE COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THAT WE REDUCE AND
ULTIMATELY ELIMINATE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP AND CYBER CITY
MATTERS SO BEFORE I START WITH
WITH MY EIGHT STATEMENTS I
BRIEFLY WANT TO SHARE MY
BACKGROUND AND MY PURPOSE THE
SUPERINTENDENT PRESIDENT
BECAUSE THAT. REALLY UP
CONVEYED. WHY ARE WE SO IT'S TO
ENSURE THAT. OUR FACULTY AND
OUR EMPLOYEES AND JOHN ALL
REPRESENT THE STUDENTS AS FAST
AS THEY CAN. SO I AM A FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE GRADUATE.
PROUD DAUGHTER OF FARM WORKERS
THAT WORK IN THE FIELDS OF A
PRO VALLEY AND COACHELLA VALLEY.
I NEVER PRESUME TO AYE WITH
EARN ANYTHING ABOVE- BACHELORS
MUCH LESS BECOME THE FIRST
FEMALE SUPERINTENDENT PRESIDENT
PROPELLED VALLEY COLLEGE IN THE
HISTORY OF THE COLLEGE. I WAS
THE FIRST FEMALE- VICE
PRESIDENT THIS IS THE FIRST
FEMALE OF MINORITY FEMALE
ACTING BP OF ACADEMIC SERVICES.
YEAH THE COLLEGE PROVIDED ME
THE FOUNDATION TO COME WHY AM
AND THE SUCCESS THAT I WOULD
CHEAT. AND IT IS WITH THOSE
INTERSECTION MALADIES THAT I
LEAVE THE INSTITUTION AND I
SERVE COMMUNITY. AND I AM SURE
THAT. WE AS IN ITS IT SHOULD
ARE DOING THE BEST WE CAN FOR
STUDENTS IT IS ABOUT THE
STUDENTS IT'S ABOUT THE HOPE
THAT WE REPRESENT AS AN
INSTITUTION. SO I WOULD SHARE
MY PURPOSE WHEN IT'S VERY BRIEF.
MY PURPOSE IS TO LEAD
INSTITUTIONAL TRANSFORMATION
THERE FORWARD THINKING CHANGE
THE MAKE STUDENTS THE CENTER
BAR WORKING ENVIRONMENT AND IT
IS FOCUSED ON INCREASING
STUDENT SUCCESS EQUITY AND
ACCESS TO HIGHER EDUCATION.
WITH THAT SAID I I'M GOING TO
SHARE COOLEY- OUR STATS AND YOU
HAVE A DOCUMENT THAT REFLECTS
THAT THE COMMUNITY OF APRIL
COUNTY IS COMPRISED OF ALL
EIGHTY FOUR PERCENT. LET THE
NUMBER COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT
PERCENT OF OUR STUDENTS AT
IMPERIAL VALLEY COLLEGE ARE
LIKE THE MOST. THAT THAT'S OF
THE EMPLOYEES OF THE
INSTITUTION. 54% OF THE FACULTY
ARE LATINOS AND I DO WANT TO
EMPHASIZE IS THAT OF THE
FACULTY SO THE THAT'S
REPRESENTED THERE. THE MAJORITY
ARE FULL TIME EMPLOYEES SO 67%
OF THOSE THE FACULTY MEMBERS
REPRESENT IN THAT THE STATISTIC
ARE FULL TIME EMPLOYEES. I'VE
THE HAS THE SECOND HIGHEST.
PERCENTAGE OF FULL TIME FACULTY
MEMBERS AND 83% OF THE FIGHT
PLEASE LET ME KNOW. AND FINALLY
40% OF THE ADMINISTRATORS ARE
LET THE NO I DO WANT TO.
PROBABLY SHARE THAT WE'VE WE'VE
IMPROVED TREMENDOUSLY- WE HIRED
THE FIRST FEMALE CHIEF BUSINESS
OFFICER IN THE IN THE HISTORY
OF THE COLLEGE. WHO HAPPENS TO
BE LUCKY ENOUGH WE HIRED THE
FIRST PERMANENT MINORITY FEMALE
VP OF ACADEMICS SERVICES. IN
THE THREE OF THE COLLEGE WHICH
HAPPENS TO BE LET THE NOT AND
I'M NOT STATING THAT THEY WERE
HIRED. BECAUSE OF GENDER OR
ETHNICITY. BUT THERE IS A
COMMITMENT TO ENSURE THAT AS AN
INSTITUTION WE'RE TRYING TO
REPRESENT WHO WE SERVE. AND.
ONE OF THE WAYS THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO IT LEAVE THAT IS WHICH
IS THE RESULT WE CRITICAL WAY
IT'S REALLY TO REVIEW DISTRICT
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES AND AT
IBC WITH THE PERFECTLY REVISED
OR ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE TO
HOP. GREEN. APPLICANTS AND TO
LEAD THE INTERVIEW PROCESS AND
ULTIMATELY TO HIRE AND THAT'S
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE
SEVENTY ONE TWENTY I DO WANT TO
SHARE THAT WITH IN THAT
PROCEDURE EVERY COMMITTEE IS
LED BY A MANAGER OR IN THE
MINISTRY. WE PREVIOUSLY- LOUD
FOR THOSE COMMITTEES TO BE LED
BY FACULTY MEMBERS OR-
DEPARTMENT CHAIRS IN AND I AND
VERY RESPECTFULLY I SAY THAT
BUT IT'S TRUE- THERE ARE
CERTAIN. DEPARTMENTS THAT IF
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY OBVIOUSLY
WITH HIGHER ONLY PEOPLE THAT
LOOK. LIKE THEM OR THAT THEY
THEMSELVES RELATE TO. I ALSO
DON'T SEE IT I'M NOT SURE I
UNDERSTOOD THE CHART YES TO A
AT THAT I'M LOOKING AT ON
FACULTY COULD COULD YOU JUST GO
OVER WITH ME. THE BECAUSE I I'M
NOT SO SURE THAT I UNDERSTAND
LIKE THE COLOR SCHEME YEAH SO
ON FACULTY. FIFTY FOUR POINT
TWO. PERCENT ARE A LOT ABOUT
THE YEAH THIRTY SEVEN POINT 1%
ARE WHITE. AND FOUR POINT SEVEN.
PERCENT OTHER- WHICH INCLUDE
AFRICAN AMERICAN MIDDLE EASTERN
AND SOME THAT COULD SELVES AS
OTHER. THANK YOU. IN IN THIS
REVIEW PROCESS- I DO WANT TO
CONVEY THAT AS THE
SUPERINTENDENT PRESENT ONE OF
MY MAJOR RESPONSIBILITIES IS TO
HIRE AND I HOLD AN INFORMAL
INTERVIEW WITH EVERY EVERY
FACULTY FINALISTS. AND
OBVIOUSLY EVERY MINISTRY
FINALLY AND WHY IS THAT
CRITICAL BECAUSE THE FACULTY
ESPECIALLY THE ONES IN THE
CLASSROOM ARE THE ONES THAT
WILL. DEAL WITH THE STUDENT
MUCH MORE FREQUENTLY IF A
STUDENT REMAINS ENGAGED IS
STUDENT REMAINS RETAIN WITH
WHICH ULTIMATELY LEADS TO A
GREATER PROBABILITY OF
COMPLETION AND DURING THAT IN
FOR MY INTERVIEW I INCLUDE THE
STUDENTS. AND OUR CONVERSATION
IT'S ALL BASED ON WHO MY
STUDENTS ARE. WHY SHOULD I HIRE
YOU WHAT WHICH YOU. CONTRIBUTE
TO THE SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS
HOW WE CONTRIBUTE TO THE
SUCCESS OF OUR STUDENTS. AND I
UP TO NOW THE STUDENT NIGHT
HOLD A DISCUSSION AFTER EVERY-
IN FOR MY INTERVIEW WE HAVE
AGREED ON WHO NEED TO BE HIRED
AND REALLY WHO ELSE WILL KNOW
MOM THEN THE STUDENT I ASK THE
STUDENTS WHO DO YOU WHO WOULD
YOU PREFER TO HAVE A FRIEND UP
YOU TEACHING. AND NOT EVERY
HIGHER. IS OF. OR THE DESIGN.
BECAUSE MY PRIORITY IS TO HIRE
SOMEONE THAT'S COMMITTED. TO
SERVING MY STUDENTS AND THAT
WILL DO WHATEVER THEY CAN TO
SUPPORT THEIR SUCCESS. WHEN WE
HIRE AND THIS HAS BEEN-
IMPLEMENT AND THE LAST TWO
YEARS WE HOPE THE NEW EMPLOYEE
ORIENTATION FOR ON ON ALL
EMPLOYEES INCLUDING ARE PART
TIME FACULTY MEMBERS. BUT I
ALSO WHERE I FOCUS A LOT ABOUT
MY BACKGROUND MY PHILOSOPHY AND
MY EXPECTATIONS WHICH IS REALLY
TO ENSURE STUDENTS AT THE
CENTER OF WHAT WE DO. AT NIGHT
THEN AN INVITATION TO EVERY NEW
PERMANENT TO MEET WITH ME
PERSONALLY WHERE WE- TALK ABOUT
THEIR PRIORITIES BUT ALSO MY
PRIORITIES. V. IT BROKEN MAKE
COLLEGE DISTRICT BOARD HAS ALSO
PRIORITIZE. IN THEIR ANNUAL
GOALS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
ENSURE THERE ARE HIRING
POLICIES AND PRACTICES ARE FAIR.
EQUITABLE AND INCLUSIVE SO
OBVIOUSLY NOT ONLY IS IT. A
PRIORITY FOR ME BUT IT'S ALSO A
PRIORITY FOR THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES TO ENSURE THAT OUR
EMPLOYEES ARE REFLECTIVE OF THE
STUDENTS THAT WOULD STIR. WHEN
THE V. TOOLS THAT WE USE USE.
AND IMPLEMENT IT RECENTLY WITH
AN ONLINE APPLICATION TO WHICH
MANY OTHER COLLEGES HAVE
ALREADY IMPLEMENTED NAY AUG OF
OR SIMILAR TOOLS AND WITHIN
THAT TO ITS ITS BECAME VERY
EASY TO TRACK WHO'S APPLYING.
OBVIOUSLY WE TRACK FOR
APPLICANTS THAT ARE THERE ARE
THERE IS NO CITIES WHERE THEY
APPLYING FROM AND. WE ALSO
OBVIOUSLY YOU TO LIFE THAT TO
INFORM OUR AND OUR OUR
PRACTICES ARE HIRING PRACTICES
THAT'S WE MOVE FORWARD. WHAT
ARE SOME OF THE MAJOR
CHALLENGES AS I SEE THEM FROM
MY STANDPOINT WITHIN FOR THE
SYSTEM. AS PREVIOUSLY STATED
THERE ARE SEVENTY THREE
DISTRICTS A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
COLLEGES. AND WE ALL DIFFERENT
PROCEDURES FOR RECRUITING AND
SCREENING POTENTIAL CANDIDATES.
FOR ME WHEN I THINK AS I STATED
WHAT'S MOST CRITICAL OF THE
POLICIES. AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THOSE POLICIES AS OUR
SYSTEM- PARTICIPATES OR IN.
INCLUDES PARTICIPATORY
GOVERNANCE IN OUR DECISION
MAKING NOT. IT IS THE ACADEMIC
SENATE WHO SUPPORTS US WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO IMPLEMENT
MODIFY POLICIES. AND NOT ONLY
THEM OTHER PARTICIPATORY
GOVERNANCE COMMITTEES AND IT IS
THOSE COMMITTEES THAT PICKED UP
HOLD THE CHANGE IN POLICY. SO
IT'S I'M THANKFUL THAT MARY IS
AND THAT AND ALLEN ALLY AND
ADVOCATE AND A SUPPORT OF OUR
OF OUR STUDENTS AND REALLY
SOMEONE THAT THE PORTS. WHAT WE
NEEDED TO. WHICH IS IN THE BEST
INTERESTS OF STUDENTS. I'M SOME
ANOTHER TELLING THAT I SEE IS
THAT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT YES WE COULD
CONTINUE HIRING AND STRIVE TO
ENSURE WE MODIFY POLICIES
PROCEDURES- THAT WE TRAIN OUR
INTERVIEW COMMITTEE. BUT
REALITY WHEN WE MAKE A HIGHER
AT AT A COMMUTE COLLEGE I THINK
ABOUT WE'RE HIRING FOR THE NEXT
TWENTY TO THIRTY YEARS MOST
LIKELY THESE EMPLOYEES SPECIAL.
AT APRIL VALLEY COLLEGE WILL
REMAIN HERE FOR A LONG TIME
WHICH IS WHY IT'S CRITICAL THAT
FOR THE EMPLOYEES THAT WE HAVE
HIRED WE PROVIDE. AND
CONSCIOUS. WE PROVIDE. CITY
COMPENSATED. CAN SEE TRAINING
AND EQUITY MINUS A BECAUSE-
ESPECIALLY THOSE THAT HAVE BEEN
THERE A LONG TIME. WE SERVE THE
STUDENTS THAT WE SERVE. AND
UNDER MY LEADERSHIP WE'RE
COMMITTED TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE
READY FOR THE STUDENTS THAT WE
HAVE. THAT THE EMPLOYEES DON'T
THINK THAT THE STUDENT NEEDS TO
COME READY TO YOU WHERE THE
INSTITUTION THAT NEEDS TO BE
READY FOR WHO THEY ARE AND WE
NEED TO CONTINUE ENHANCING
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE. THAT.
DON'T UNDERSTAND OUR STUDENTS
AS BEST AS THEY CAN. AND
FINALLY MY RECOMMENDATIONS ARE.
AS AS THE- I CAN ACHIEVE THIS
THE LOAN- IT IS WITH THE
SUPPORT AND COMMITMENT OF THE
EMPLOYEES THAT I WORK WITH AND
IT IS IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT
I BILL. THE TEAM AND SUPPORT
THE TEAM THAT I RECOGNIZE
POTENTIAL WITHIN THE EMPLOYEES
AS TO WHO COULD AS PLANNED TO
HIGHER ROLES- AND THAT
ULTIMATELY I AM EMPOWER THEM.
TO TRANSFORM THE INSTITUTION TO
WHAT I ENVISION THE INSTITUTION
WILL BECOME FIVE YEARS FROM NOW.
IDENTIFYING FACULTY AND STAFF
THAT'S COMMITTING TO ENHANCING.
DIVERSE CITY AND THAT'S
COMMITTED TO INCLUSION AND IT'S
CRITICAL. BECAUSE THERE ARE LA
IF THEY'RE THE ONES THAT ARE
SPENDING MOST OF THE TIME ON
CAMPUS- AND NOT THAT WE DON'T
AS AS AS FEELS HOWEVER THERE
THE WEDNESDAY INTERACTING WITH
THE STUDENTS THE MOST. ADD TO
PARTNER. WITH HUMAN RESOURCES
IT IS THAT. OBVIOUSLY I
CONVEYED WHAT THE PRIORITY AND
THAT WE WORK TOGETHER TO.
HOPEFULLY ACHIEVE THE
PRIORITIES AND THE LAST ONE.
RETAINING ARE AMAZING EMPLOYEES.
IT IT HAS BEEN CONVEYED THAT WE
HAVE GREAT EMPLOYEES AT SOME OF
THE INSTITUTIONS AND WE'RE NOT
ATTAINING THEM IN THE WAY THAT
WE SHOULD FOR VARIOUS REASONS
BUT- AT THE END OF THE DAY IT'S
THE CAMP. COLD THE US. INVADING
SINCERELY OUR APPRECIATION AND
EMPOWERING THEM TO WHO E.
INNOVATIVE. REMINDING THEM THAT
THEY BE LONG THAT WILL RETAIN
THEM SO WITH THAT I AND MY
COMMENTS AND I THANK YOU
SINCERELY. THANK YOU. SEVEN
WOMEN NEED TO TURN IT ON I'M
NOT NERVOUS. ACTUALLY MY NAME'S
MERRY GRIN AND I AM THE
ACADEMIC SENATE PRESIDENT ADAM
FOR ABOUT A COLLEGE BUT FIRST
AND FOREMOST I AM B. E. OPS
COUNSELOR AND HAVE BEEN ONE FOR
TWENTY YEARS- SO. UPS IS
ACTUALLY THE ORIGINAL STUDENT
EQUITY AND WHAT THE DANCE
ASSESSMENT OR WHAT WE CALL
ACHIEVEMENTS I CAN'T KEEP TRACK
OF ALL THESE- NEW PROGRAMS WE
HAVE BUT WE WERE THE ORIGINAL
ONES THAT SUCCESSFULLY FOR
YEARS SO WHEN I WAS A- SPEAKER
ON I'VE NEVER DONE THIS BEFORE
I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW WHERE TO
START. SO STUDENT WHEN HE
STARTED KINDERGARTEN IN
MINNESOTA HE SPOKE WITH ME NOT
SPANISH SWEDISH SOME.
INTERESTING THOUGH I LIKE TO
CONVEY THAT TO MY STUDENTS- HE
DIDN'T GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL HE WENT INTO THE
MILITARY WORLD WAR TWO MY MOM
DID SOME COLLEGE BUT I ALWAYS
HAD. THAT FOR MY PARENTS
GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL I KNEW I
WANTED TO GO TO COLLEGE- WHEN I
STARTED I YOU SEE I WAS A
SINGLE. THE WHAT. CHILD.
PICTURE LOPEZ STARTED A PROGRAM
CALLED IT GROW YOUR OWN AND
WHAT THAT MEANT WAS HE WAS
GIVING PEOPLE ALREADY HAVE MY
MASTER'S DEGREE BUT HE WOULD
GIVE YOU THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
IN A MASTER'S PROGRAM COMPLETED
AND YOU WORK PART TIME TO GET
TO THE- EXPERIENCE SHE NEEDED
TO GO OUT AND BE A COUNSELOR.
I'D SAY THAT 90% OF THE
COUNSELORS IN HER EARLY ARE DID
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK AT
I WE SEE AT ONE POINT OR ARE
YOU ARE ARE YOU SEE ALONE- WHEN
I STARTED- BECAUSE THAT WAS IN
THE EIGHTIES ON A- I DIDN'T GET
TOO INVOLVED WITH HE'S ON
CAMPUS I WAS LIKE THE REPORT
THAT THE PREFERRED. TO JUST
WENT TO THEIR DOG AND. TWO
THOUSAND TO ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES IN SAID GET INVOLVED
WITH SENATE SO I DID. I'VE BEEN
ON THE ACADEMIC SENATE FOR
EIGHTEEN YEARS I'VE BEEN THE
PRESIDENT FOR THE LAST FOUR. SO
I THINK IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE I
WAS TRYING TO DO SOME RESEARCH
WHEN DID SENATE REALLY GET
INVOLVED WITH THE HIRING
PRACTICES HR. THE DIRECTOR OF
THE TIME CAME TO SENATE
DISCUSSED- THE NEED FOR A SIM
MAKE CHANGES AND WE WERE ALWAYS
POSITIVE. WITH WITH- APPROACH
AND I THINK. THAT WOULD JUST
SOME QUICK STATS. WITH OUR OUR
FACULTY IN TWO THOUSAND WE HAD.
EIGHTY NINE FULL TIME FACULTY
BY THE TIME A TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN ROLLED AROUND WE HAD
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE OF FEMALE
FACULTY IN TWO THOUSAND THIRTY
NINE HOME OR 44% AND- BY THE
TIME TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
ROLLED AROUND WE HAD SEVENTY
SIX. THE MALE POPULATION IN TWO
THOUSAND OF FACULTY WAS FIFTY
AND IT GREW TO SEVENTY FIVE
SORT. OF A FEW MORE- AND THEN
WE DO. HAVE MEANT OKAY BUT- I
THINK THIS MOVIE CAN INCREASE
AND I JUST PICKED THE HISPANIC.
THE WHITE- FULL TIME FACULTY ON
OUR CAMPUS LIKE MORE TO SAID.
ON 92% OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
HISPANIC AND RIGHT NOW WE HAVE
A FACULTY THAT IS 42% HISPANIC.
BUT THAT'S A GROWTH FROM 21% IN
TWO THOUSAND SO WE'RE MAKING.
WE'RE IN WE'RE IN. MAKING
PROGRESS WE HAVE A FACULTY THAT
IS. A MORE DIVERSE THAN IT HAS
BEEN IN THE PAST- WE HAVE HAD
AN INCREASE IN BLOCK OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN FACULTY. AND ASIAN. OF
FACULTY IN EVEN THOUGH WE'VE
HIRED. USE IT WILL BE SO I
THINK WHAT AND IN THE VALLEY
SINCE WE'RE THE ONLY CAMPUS YOU
KNOW WE'RE A HUNDRED AND-
TWENTY MILES AWAY FROM ANY OF
THE COLLEGES HOME IN SAN DIEGO
THAT WERE DISTRICT PART OF. A
WE HAVE A HUGE- TIME FACULTY
THAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO HIRE
FULL TIME FROM WE HAVE
ENCOURAGE THEM TO APPLY FOR THE
JOBS WE'VE OFFERED THEM THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO AFTER.
HAVING WORKED WITH US. I THINK.
AXIS DOCUMENT BUT IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN WHEN WE
ADOPTED OUR- YOU YO PLAN IT WAS
APPROVED IT WAS VETTED THROUGH
DIFFERENT- COMMITTEES BUT SAID
IT WAS RIGHT THERE IN THE FOR
IT WE DON'T DISCUSS TO QUITE A
BIT IT WAS APPROVED BY OUR
BOARD OF TRUSTEES. AND I THINK
GO DO YOU GO HIRING PROCESS
THAT WE APPROVED OF ALL OF THIS
MAKE UP OF THE EIGHTIES SENATE-
WHEN IT COMES TO DISTRIBUTORS
HAS TO FACULTY MEMBERS ON THAT
HIRING COMMITTEE WHEN IT COMES
TO A FACULTY POSITION I GET TO
CHOOSE FROM AND I DON'T TAKE
THAT LONG- FACULTY I. PUT AN
EMAIL OUT. ALL THEY WERE.
HIRING COMMITTEE. WHAT IT IS
AND I. GET TO CHOOSE. WHO EVER
RESPONSE BUT WE ALSO HAVE. A
FACULTY MEMBER FROM THAT AREA
IT'S ENGLISH THERE'S THE
ENGLISH FACULTY MEMBER. ON THAT
COMMITTEE. THE THAT'S LOOKING
AT PICKING IN THE ON A NEW
FACULTY WORK MOST OF TIME THE
TWO. OF FACULTY MEMBERS ARE
FROM THE DIVISION. I HOW TO
MAKE A COMMENT ABOUT WHEN
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MATH HOME
AND MATH FACULTY. OF WELL I'VE-
SEEN THAT IN THE PAST WHERE
THEY WANT TO HIRE. SOMEBODY
WITH THE PHD. AND AT IBC IT'S-
BUDGET. WHAT WE GET THE STATE
CANNOT RELATE TO OUR STUDENT
BODY- AND THAT'S A THAT'S A
SHAME ONE MORE COMMENT I'D LIKE
TO MAKE IS A WHOLE TENURE
PROCESS SO RIGHT ARE YOU HAVE
BEEN VERY- TRIED TO BE VERY
INCLUSIVE WITH OUR NEW FOUND.
BOB IS A- FIRST YOUR FAT
COMMITTEES. OR YOU GET THE MENU
GET THE NEW FACULTY IN THERE
YOU INTRODUCED INTO THE SCHOOL
THEY HAVE LITTLE SOCIAL EVENTS
IS SOMEBODY FOR THEM TO BOND
WITH AND HOPEFULLY GET THAT
FEELING THAT THEY BELONG ON THE
CAMPUS. DARN EVERYONE OF THOSE
SENIOR MOMENTS. OF THE WORLD
WAS GOING WITH THIS WE HAVE. WE
DO HAVE ADDITIONAL OF TRAINING
FOR OUR FACULTY WE DEVELOPED
AND STARTED A TLC TEACHING
LEARNING CENTER WHICH HAS BEEN
VERY- OF PRODUCTIVE IN IN GOING
OUT AND OFFERING WORKSHOPS SO
THAT OUR FACULTY ARE WHERE WHAT
IT'S LIKE TO TEACH IN OUR
CULTURE YOUR CULTURALLY DIVERSE
POPULATION. ACTUALLY THERE
REALLY. PREDOMINATELY HISPANIC
BUT THE I'VE LIVED IN THE ONLY
LONG ENOUGH TO EMBRACE THE
CULTURE AND UNDERSTAND THE
STUDENTS WERE COMING FROM.
THEIR INTERACTION WITH- A
LEADERSHIP IN PEOPLE OR THAT
THEY LOOK AT IS LIKE PROFESSORS
ARE. ALMOST KIND OF PERFECT
LIKE I DON'T CHALLENGE A
PROFESSOR THAT TIME THAT
ATTITUDE OR TRY TO GET THEM TO
CHANGE- BUT BECAUSE I AM I AM
ACCOUNTS ARE GOING TO TAUGHT.
FOR EIGHTEEN YEARS AND A
PSYCHOLOGY. SO WHY. WE. TRYING
TO EMPOWER FOR OUR OUR FACULTY
TO LEARN MORE ABOUT THIS HE
SAID THEY ALL WORK WITH AND-
AND WORK WITH STUDENTS SERVICES
I AM STUDENT SERVICES SIDE OF
THE HOUSE FIRST AND FOREMOST-
I'M I'M ONLY THE SECOND STUDENT
SERVICES SENATE. PERSON. AND
THE SECOND WOMAN SO HE'S GIVING.
IS AS SHE SAID SHE TOLD ME WHEN
YOU START TALKING VERY IT'S
GOING TO GO LIKE THAT SO YES
THEY DO THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR ME I'LL
BE HAPPY TO. MEET YOU BACK
THERE AND- I NEED TO GO M. AND
WITH THAT. BINDER THAT WE ONLY
HAVE ROOM ONE O'CLOCK. WE'LL
HAVE ANOTHER PANEL STILL TO GO.
SO PLEASE THANK YOU FOR
CONSCIOUS OF THE TIME. THE SUIT
DID ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE AUDIENCE THANK
YOU FOR IMMEDIATE TO INDIA OR
US RATHER TO SPEAK ABOUT
CENTERS A. COMMITTEE COLLEGE
SENATE COMMITTEE COLLEGES PART
DISTRICTS SO WE ARE CENTERS A.
CITY COLLEGE AND EVERGREEN-
COMMITTEE COLLEGE AND THE
REASON I BRING THAT UP. BECAUSE
IN LAST. OCTOBER IN AUGUST
TWENTY OF TWENTY NINETEEN THE A
CRITICAL PART OF YOUR
EDUCATION- DIVERSITY IN INDEX
OF MENTIONED THAT EVERGREEN WAS
NUMBER TWO AT SAN JOSE CITY WAS
NUMBER SEVEN. OF ALL OF THE TWO
YEAR PUBLIC EDUCATION. SYSTEM
IN THE ENTIRE UNITED STATES IN
TERMS OF DIVERSITY SO BOTH PART
OF BOTH COLLEGES. HAVE DONE A
BILL WOULD DRESSED. SENATE IS A
COLLEGE WE WENT. IN OUR BASE
YEAR OF TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE
FROM. 47% OF AND REPRESENTED
FACULTY MEMBERS TO IN TWENTY.
EIGHT EIGHTEEN NOT UNDER
REPRESENTED THAT'S A HUGE GAME
AND- WE'VE BEEN HAS A HISPANIC
SERVER SHOULD YOU SHOULD SYSTEM
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WE'RE ALMOST
DID YOU. AND WE'RE ONE OF THE
HEART THE LONGEST SERVING
COMMITTEE CALL JUST SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. WE HAVE A VERY HIGH
TRANSFER RATE FOR. STUDENTS IN
THE LAST YEAR WE REPORTED ONE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED DEGREES.
NOW WHAT I LIKE TO SAY ABOUT
THAT IS THAT EVEN THE WORST
SMALL COLLEGE THAT HAS MAYBE
NINE THOUSAND STUDENTS. ARE
GRADUATION AT IS ATTENDED BY
FORTY THOUSAND GAS BECAUSE THEY
ARE A DEGREES IS WHICH OF
COURSE MEANS SO MUCH TO OUR
COMMUNITY. IN PART OF THE HAS
BEEN IN THE. THE WITH THE
DIRECTION OF THE BOARD SO THE
BOARD HAS COMMITTED TO
DIVERSITY AND AS YOU SEE ON THE
FIRST PAGE THERE IS. THERE'S A
BOARD POLICIES SEVEN ONE ZERO
ZERO AND THEN MR POLICY SEVEN
ONE ZERO ZERO AND IT'S COMMITS
US TO DIVERSITY RECOGNIZES
DIVERSITY AND HIRING
DEVELOPMENT THE PROCEDURES AND
THEN- THAT LOOKS OF THE STUDENT
BODY AND ARE PROP. SHOULD AS-
AT OUR PLACE AS VERY IMPORTANT
SO ON THE SECOND PAGE WE HAVE
THE FACULTY THIS IS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE. COSTS ARE
PROFESSIONALS AND THE FIRST
YEAR THAT WE- USED AS A BAIT
BENCHMARK WITH PART OF OUR. EOC
REPORT IT WAS TO THAT FIVE. THE
COURT WILL WIN 200-052-2000
EIGHTEEN IN TERMS OF. FACULTY
DIVERSITY WE WENT FROM 40%
UNDER REPRESENTED TO SIXTY
SEVEN. WITH EYES GROWTH BEING
HISPANIC A FACULTY MEMBERS THAT
IF YOU LOOK AT OUR STUDENTS
WE'VE ALWAYS BEEN A VERY
DIVERSE CAMPUS WITH ABOUT 80%
OF OUR STUDENTS BEING UNDER
REPRESENTED FOR EIGHTY FIVE-
BUT YET OUR FACULTY IN OUR
HISTORY HIRES DIDN'T REFLECT
THAT. SO IN. TWO THOUSAND FIVE
BAR ADMINISTRATION WAS- 48%
UNDER REPRESENTED AND IN TWO
THOUSAND AND 1883% OR PERCENT.
WE'VE MADE A LOT OF STE OF
GAINES AND PART OF OUR GAINES
REALLY BECAUSE- PARTICULARLY
WITH OUR FACULTY WE REALLY LOOK
AT THE TV DEMONSTRATION. THE
ABILITY OF OUR FACULTY TO WORK
WITH OUR STUDENTS WHO ARE OTHER
UNDERPREPARED OR FROM DIVERSE
BACKGROUNDS IN THE READ STYLES.
AND THEN- ALSO WE HAVE OUR
ACADEMIC SAID IT IS SENATE A
PRESIDENT THAT IS. AT. ALL OF
OUR HIRING. OF FOR BOTH
ADMINISTRATORS AND FOR FACULTY.
AND THEN ALSO- THAT IS PART OF
THE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR JOB
DESCRIPTIONS- WE ALSO HAVE A
REALLY GREAT SUPPORT NETWORK SO
WE HAVE TO ASSOCIATIONS THAT
WE'RE PROUD OF. LATE WHICH IS
THE LEAD LATINO EDUCATIONAL
ASSOCIATION AND THE A. P. I. A
WHICH IS ASIAN PACIFIC
ISLANDERS ASSOCIATION STORE TO
LARGER STUDENT GROUPS ARE
LUCKY. AND EIGHT. SO THOSE ARE
SOME HIGHLIGHTS OF OUR WHAT.
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE.
MORNING MORNING I'M TRYING TO
THINK HOW ON IS THE YOU WILL BE.
I THINK ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS
THAT WE'RE HERE IS BECAUSE YOU
REALLY WANT TO HEAR WHAT IS IT
THAT HAVE DONE. OUR INSTITUTION
HOW IS IT THAT WE HAVE BREAK
INTO THIS WELL THE BARRIERS AND
REMOVING ALL THE WALLS SO THAT
WE'RE ABLE TO LIKE THEIR FROM
THE- EARTH. BY MICHAEL D. I AM.
MERRILY BUT WE HAVE ALSO AND IT
AT IN WITHIN THEIR THIS AND THE
ONE THING I REALLY WANTED YOU
WITH IS THAT. YOU HAVE TO
RECRUIT LEADERS THERE ARE
UNAPOLOGETIC BECAUSE I THINK-
THE PREVIOUS PRESENTERS-
PRESIDENT NEW AND- DOCTOR
GONZALEZ IN MICHELLE. THEY HAVE
BASICALLY PRESENTED TO YOU THE
CASE THEY HAVE GIVEN YOU THE
DATE THAT THEY HAD GIVEN THE
THINGS I'M NOT EVEN GONNA TRY
TO GO INTO THAT AREA AREA WHICH
I AM ALSO A DATA DRIVEN CRAZY
INDIVIDUAL. I'M IN NO HAVING
ABOUT ME NUMBER THEN YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA- METAL.
I'VE IF ANYTHING WOULD MAKE
MORE MISTAKES. HOWEVER AS AN
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT MYSELF. AS
A FORMER LET THESE IN NETWORK
AND ALSO- SB FIVE FORTY-
DREAMER. ON THERE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER VIABLE WHEN I
DID MY FIRST HEARING AS A
STUDENT AND AS AN UNDERGRAD
THAT I NEEDED TO DISCLOSE THAT
REALLY TALK ABOUT MY EXPERIENCE
IN ALL OF THOSE THINGS. HE
NEVER STOPS ME FROM ROOM.
CONNECTING IN CORRELATING TO
THE FEAR OUR FACULTY OF COLOR
HAVE WHEN THEY ARE HIGHER. IS
THIS YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT PART
TIMERS WHY IS IT THAT ARE PART
TIME A POLICE NOT BIG ENOUGH
WELL IT'S PRETTY OBVIOUS THE
MAJORITY OF US THAT ARE
GRADUATING OUR FIRST GENERATION
STUDENTS WE WANT TO GET IT IN
OKAY FOR A FAMILY FOR WHOM WE-
ARE LOANS. TAKE OUR KIDS. SO
WHEN WE HAVE. MASTER'S DEGREE A
WE HAVE A DOCTOR DEGREE I'M
GOING TO BE TRAVELING FROM ONE
COLLEGE TO ANOTHER- WE'RE GONNA
GET HIGHER MAYBE I WANT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND WE HAVE
TO DRIVE TWENTY FIVE THIRTY THE
WAY TO GO WORK AT ANOTHER
COLLEGE SO THEY PART TIME TO
REALLY BECOME VERY ATTRACTIVE
IN THE PAIN. ACTUALLY IT'S NOT
GOING. THERE GOES ONE ANSWER
WIRE POOL IS SO SMALL THAT. THE
MEANS THAT. IS AN EXCUSE TO SAY
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH OF
THEM WE NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB
RECRUITING INDIVIDUALS OF COLOR
SO THEY CAN ACTUALLY SEE THIS
IS A GOOD PAYING POSITION IT IS
VERY REWARDING BECAUSE IT
DIDN'T AND IS A POSITION THAT
THEY DESERVE TO BE THERE. FROM
MODELS TO OUR STUDENTS. SEC
WHEN I REFER TO AN APOLOGETIC.
WILLING TO CONFRONT THE MICRO
AGGRESSIONS THAT IS WILLING TO
GO UP FRONT THE CULTURE THAT IS
WILLING TO QUESTION THE
PRACTICES POLICIES PROCEDURES
AND IS WILLING TO GO FARTHER
AND ABOUT. WHAT'S HAPPENING AT
YOUR INSTITUTION AND IF YOU'RE
NOT DOING THOSE THINGS BUT
YOU'RE THE LEADER TO BE APPLES
LOCAL AREAS DOCTOR GONZALEZ
MADE A VERY CLEAR THE CHANGES
THAT YOU WANT TO SEE IN THIS
SYSTEM ARE HAPPENED LOCALLY AND
THE ONLY WAY THEY CAN HAPPEN
LOCAL. IS BECAUSE I DID THEM.
AS YOU LOOK AT THE DATE. THE
MIX PRESIDENT. BACK IN
200-010-2000 ELEVEN. EXCEPT
PRESIDENT YES THE YOUNGEST ONE
IN THE GROUP A FACULTY MEMBER
APPROACHING HIS AS WHEN YOU
BECOME FACULTY MET- ACADEMICS
IN A PRESIDENT NOT RETIRING AS
IT WERE ON. I DID HE RETIRE.
THOSE ARE GREAT DOT THAT WERE
HAVING AS FACULTY OF COLOR. AND
DON'T FORGET ABOUT THE MANY
DARK SKIN. AND SCARS AND
EVERYTHING WE KERRY IN THE
INSTITUTION BECAUSE HERE COMES
FAVIO HOPE HE'S HE'S VERY LOUD
BY THE WAY HE JUST COME HERE
PURCHASE FOR ASKING AND
REQUESTING THAT WE HAVE TO
FOLLOW THESE. DIFFERENT THINGS
WHY YOU'RE STILL DEMANDING.
BECAUSE IT'S COME DOWN TO HOW
YOU DEVELOP A COLD. LUCY
MISTING WELCOMING FOR STUDENTS
OF COLOR. THE REWARDS THAT WE
ARE SEEN TO DATE IS THAT OUR
LOCAL FEATURES ARE BECOMING
MORE AWARE MORE AWARE OF OUR
PHD. IN CHEMISTRY MATH PHYSICS
OUT WE HAVE TO RECENTLY LET THE
MASS WHO THE TENURE TRACK FOR
MATHEMATICS I'M I CAN HONESTLY
TELL PROBABLY WOULD HAVE NEVER
BEEN CONSIDERED TO HAVE THE
STATE YOUR POSITION IF YOU.
BECAUSE OF THE POSITION ACT A
BIT MINISTRATION. HEY WE'RE.
STRUCTURE WE'RE GOING TO HIRE
TO AGAIN AN APOLOGETIC
APPROACHES SO MAKING SURE THAT
YOU'RE HIRING QUALITY
INDIVIDUALS BECAUSE EVEN
LATINOS IN OURSELVES WE HAVE
THE OPTIMISM THAT WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH ABOUT THE FACT THAT
WE ARE MINORITIES AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY OUR DOCTOR DEGREE EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVEN'T. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WHILE I AM NOT TO HAVE
A COMMUNITY RIGHT AWAY BECAUSE
WE ALSO DEAL WITH. IF. I'M IS
MY FATHER TO CALL LATER OR THE
PUSH BACK AS YOU WERE REFERRING
TO EARLIER. BUT THE MOST
IMPORTANT THING IS THAT THE
ACADEMIC SENATE STRUCTURES AS
MY COLLEAGUE JOHN STAND AS WELL
COME AND EXPLAIN IT TO YOU. FOR
US TO WORK LOCALLY WITH OUR
LEADERSHIP SAID. ACTUALLY MAKE
THIS HAPPEN. WE HAVE THE
MINIMUM QUALIFICATION PROCESS
WE HAVE THE HIRING PROCEDURES
THE TEMPLATE FOR. ALL INVOLVED
THERE. TO THE DNA OF THE
INSTITUTION. SO WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE COMMUNITY
WITH THE LEADERSHIP AND WORKING
TOGETHER WITH THE ACADEMIC
SENATE. THIS IS BASICALLY A
CONNECTION THAT YOU'RE ALLOWED
TO ASK THOSE QUESTIONS HAVE THE
COURAGEOUS DIALOGUE YOU START
THINKING THE PROCEDURE. YOU CAN
SEE THIS CHANGES HAPPEN. SO THE
ALLIES TO THAT BIG DIVERSE
SYFY. AND QUIRK IN MOVE THE
NEEDLE FOR. IS HAPPENING YOU
MUST. HAPPEN LOCALLY BECAUSE
THAT'S WHERE THE PROP. THE
CHANGE. WHICH IS ONE OF THE FEW.
WITH THE IDEA. OF HAVING
BESIDES THE COURAGEOUS
CONVERSATIONS IS THE LONG TERM
COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE BRING IN
THIS TO THE FOREFRONT OF
MATCHES THE ACADEMIC SENATE
THIS IS A VILLAGE OUR LABOR
UNION I'M ACTUALLY THAT ICE
PRESIDENT OF MY LOCAL IN OUR
LABOR UNIONS NEED TO TAKE SOME
LEADERSHIP ON THIS. IBM. CHOOSE
A INDIVIDUAL WHO SO WAS
QUESTIONING THE ACADEMIC SENATE
LOOKS SO WHITE. STATEWIDE COME
ON LET'S RECRUIT SOME PEOPLE
THEY LOVE PEOPLE OF COLOR WE
ACTUALLY DOCTOR CENTERS
ACTUALLY HELP US OF THE BARREL
DEVELOPING THAT DIVERSITY
COMMITTEE THAT WE HAVE ON
RECRUITING MORE LATINO FACULTY
SO THAT THEY CAN SERVE ON
LEADERSHIP POSITIONS AT THE
STATE. EXAM THE SAME THING WITH
THE UNIONS OKAY YEAH BECAUSE HE
BECAUSE HE. QUESTION IN THEM AS
WELL. THEY HAVE TO START HAVING
THIS COURAGEOUS DOG DIALOGUES
INTERNAL REVIEW ON WHAT IS
REALLY HAPPENING THIS IS A
SYSTEM WIDE SYSTEMATIC. PROCESS
THAT WE'RE LOCATING STAR ASKING
THOSE QUESTIONS BECAUSE- AND
WE'RE GONNA BE HERE SIXTY YEARS
LATER. ASKING THE SAME
QUESTIONS WHY HAVE A WE GET OUR
TO DIVERSE IDEAS SO RECRUITMENT
MARKETING MAKING SURE THAT THE-
WEBER REALLY. THIS POSITIONS
OUT THERE AND REALLY CHANGING
THE PROCEDURES IS CRITICAL ON
MAKING THE CHANGES LOCALLY
THANK YOU FIVE YOU- SAN JOSE
STATE COLLEGE WHEN LOOKING AT
YOUR CHART. FROM 14% IN TWO
THOUSAND AND FIVE LATINO 229%
IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
EIGHTEEN YEARS BUT IT ALMOST
DOUBLED IN IN IN NUMBERS DO YOU
HAVE ANY IDEA HOW MANY
POSITIONS HOW MANY FACULTY
POSITIONS THAT REPRESENTED YOU
DOUBLES I KIND OF THE NUMBERS
BECAUSE WHEN I ARRIVE AT SOME
OF THE COLLEGE THERE WAS ONLY
THREE BY LAW IN THESE AS I LIKE
TO RECORDING. ONLY THREE THREE.
YES TENURE AND NOW WE'RE ABOUT
THIRTY THREE THIRTY FOUR. OKAY
SO FROM THREE TO THIRTEEN
CARRILLO AND HAPPEN IS THAT.
WHEN YOU GO ACROSS THE STATE
THE MOST AND BY THE WAY I WAS
THE PRESIDENT OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE UPS. AND THIS
IS A CONVERSATION THAT WE COME
ACROSS AS THEY WERE STUDENT
SERVICE BUT THE MOST DIVERSE
FACULTY COME FROM STUDENT
SERVICES AND THERE'S A REASON
WHY YOU'LL BE AN ENTIRE THAT
FIRST FACULTY BECAUSE WE HAVE A
WITHIN THEIR- QUALIFICATIONS BY
THE WAY. BUT THE REALITY IS
THAT. THE NUMBER YOU GOTTA KEEP
TRACK OF THOSE NUMBERS AND LOOK
AT THAT IS. THAT YOURS. PLEASE
SELECTING A POPULATION IS THAT
YOU'RE PURPOSELY LOOKING OUT
WHAT YOUR POSITION OF FACULTY
YES AND HOW CAN YOU DIVERSE UP
BY THAT. SAM WAS THAT I THINK
IS ABOUT TWENTY YEARS AHEAD
WE'RE DEALING WITH MORE
CHALLENGING ISSUES. WHICH HE
HAS TO DO NOW THAT WORK. BY WE
HAVE SOME VERY DIVERSE
DIALOGUES ABOUT THE CULTURE-
WHAT WE'RE HAVING THERE IS
ABOUT 65% OF. THE IS FEMALE- I
SAN JOSE CITY COLLEGE SO THAT
HAS CHANGED ARE. ARE CASTING
FROM PLEASE. BEING YOU. ARE
COMING FORWARD. REMARKS. WHO
MADE TO GIVE. PROGRESS
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES WILL
CONTINUE. GOOD AFTERNOON NOW SO
GOOD AFTER YOU- MY NAME IS
CAROL ACOSTA FARRAR AND ON ICE
PRESS THE BACK THEN THE FEAR
RIVERSIDE CITY COLLEGE- AND
AGAIN AS EVERYONE ELSE HAS DONE
ON BEHALF OF WELL I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME YOU BUT ALSO ON BEHALF
OF AND GREGORY AKERS AND- I
WOULD. JUST TO PROVIDE SOME
HONEST. ASIAN OF OUR FACULTY
AND THEN REVIEW SOME OF
SERVICES AND SOME OF OUR
CHALLENGES. SO LET ME BEGIN
WITH OF THE- PM. WITH REGARD TO
BE A MALE FEMALE THE VACATION
AT RIVERSIDE CITY COLLEGE 52%
OF OUR FACULTY ARE FEMALE SO
REAL QUICK 48% AND THAT'S THERE
IS- THAT'S OF WE'RE VERY PROUD
OF THAT- WE ARE NOT SATISFIED
WITH THAT WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT ALL OF
THE SUBCATEGORIES THE COLLEGE
SO FOR EXAMPLE LOOK AT OUR
NURSING FACULTY- AS YOU MIGHT
IMAGINE. THE MAJORITY OF THAT
SIR. ALTHOUGH NOT ALL AND SO.
WHAT THE WHAT EFFORTS CAN WE
MAKE TO- RECRUIT OF MALES IN
MALE FACULTY IN OF PRIMARILY-
HISTORICALLY FEMALE AREAS AND
THE SAME. AND VICE VERSA- WE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT A LOWER A
LIBERAL ARTS FACULTY THEY'RE
FAIRLY WELL- EQUALLY- FIRST- OF
VERSES ARE STEM FACULTY WHO ARE
SLIGHTLY MORE MALE DOMINATED
BUT ONLY SLIGHTLY. WELL THAT'S
ALL OUR GENDER. STATISTICS WITH
REGARD TO THE DEMOGRAPHICS FOR.
OF FOR OUR ETHNIC OF THE
ETHNICITY OF OUR FACULTY- WITH
REGARD TO AFRICAN AMERICANS
THE- IN OUR IN THE RIVERSIDE
CITY COLLEGE SERVICE AREA SO
THE SERVICE AREA MOST NEAR OUR
COLLEGE OF COURT WE ARE- ARE A
MULTI COLLEGE DISTRICT AND OF
THE QUITE. BUT DISTRICT WE HAVE
THREE COLLEGE. IF YOU HAVE DE
ARE THE PRODUCTS OF THE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT ARE IN OUR CITY
AND OUR NEAREST CENSUS
DESIGNATED PLACES. UP THERE ARE
5% AFRICAN AMERICAN. OUR
STUDENT POPULATION IS SEVEN
POINT 4% AND OUR FACULTY ARE
SIX POINT 3% AFRICAN AMERICAN.
SIMILAR TO THE DATA THAT WAS
BOUGHT FOR BY THE CAMPAIGN FOR
CALL- COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY- THE
NUMBERS ARE SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT
BECAUSE OF WHEN THE DATA WAS
PULLED. AMERICANS COMMUNITY IS
FIFTY HI I'M SORRY FIVE POINT
SEVEN. PERCENT THE OUR STUDENTS
ARE FOUR POINT 7% AND OUR
FACULTY ARE SIX POINT 7% SO IN
THOSE TWO AREAS- WE HAVE DONE.
SOME GOOD WORK. WITH REGARD TO-
THE LATIN ACTS AND A WHITE
POPULATIONS OF MORE OF OUR
FACULTY AND STUDENTS. ARE
THAT'S WHERE WE'VE IDENTIFIED
THE LARGEST GAP. IN AMONG OUR
OF A MONARCH REGION IN OUR
SERVICE AREA IS PRETTY 1% WHITE
OUR STUDENTS ARE 20% WHITE. OUR
FACULTY ARE 68% WHITE. WITH
REGARD TO THIS BALLOT A LOT
NEXT POPULATIONS 55% AMONG OUR
WITH OUR SERVICE AREA 55% AMONG
OUR SERVICE AREA 63% OF OUR
STUDENTS. OUR OUR HISPANIC OR
LATIN NEXT AND ONLY 20% OF OUR
FACULTY. SO YOU CAN SEE IT'S IN
THOSE TWO AREAS WHERE WE HAVE.
ALLEN. SOME OF THE EFFORTS THAT.
GEN RECENTLY OR OVER THE LAST
FEW YEARS AND THEN WE'VE SENT-
SEVERAL TEAMS TO USC'S CENTER
FOR URBAN EDUCATION AND
PARTICIPATED IN THE QUEUE
TRAINING THERE I AM AS A RESULT
OF THAT WE'VE WE'VE SENT NOT
ONLY FACULTY AND ADMINISTRATORS
BUT ALSO. ON THE- SOURCES STAFF
THAT WORKS UP PRIME WITH OUR
COLLEGE. AND AS A RESULT OF
THAT- WE HAVE BEGUN ADDING
EQUITY MINDED LANGUAGE ALL OF
OUR FACULTY RECRUITMENT IN
ADDITION. IT IT HAS ALSO
RESULTED IN SOME- EXCELLENT
TRAINING FOR FACULTY IN GENERAL
WITH REGARD TO CULTURAL
COMPETENCY AND IMPLICIT BIAS-
BUT THOSE ARE MORE ISSUES THAT
IMPACT THE- THE CLASSROOM WHICH
IS CRITICAL AND IMPORTANT BUT-
NOT THE NOT THE MAIN SUBJECT
HERE WHICH IS HOW HOW ARE WE-
HELPING TO. THE FIRE APPLE
TEAM. I'M THE EQUITY MY
LANGUAGE I WANT TO. TALK ABOUT
THAT JUST FOR A SECOND ME JUST
PULL IT UP HERE. SO RIVERSIDE.
IS ONE OF THOSE COLLEGES THAT.
ON OCCASION HAS INCLUDED
LANGUAGES IN OUR JOB JOB
ADVERTISEMENTS- THAT SAYS
MASTER'S DEGREE REQUIRED AND
PHD PREFERRED IN SOME CASES.
THAT LANGUAGE WASN'T NEXT
LANGUAGE WELL IT IS ALWAYS
QUESTIONED IN REVIEW. IN OUR
MOST RECENT RECRUITMENTS LAST
YEAR EVERY JOB POSTING THAT
WENT OUT INCLUDED THE IDEAL
CANDIDATE WILL BE EQUITY MINDED
WILL SHARE OF THE COLLEGES IN
THE DEPARTMENT'S COMMITMENT TO
EDUCATING ITS WORK LATE ETHNIC
AND SOCIO ECONOMICALLY DIVERSE
STUDENT POPULATION. AND WILL BE.
INSTEAD IN CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE PEDAGOGY PEDAGOGICAL
PRACTICES FOR ENGAGING LE LET
X. HISPANIC AFRICAN AMERICAN
NATIVE AMERICAN AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER STUDENTS WHICH ARE
HISTORICALLY UNDERSERVED. THE
JOB DESCRIPTIONS ALL ONE TWO
REFERENCE OUR PERCENTAGE- THERE
ARE AMONG OUR STUDENT
POPULATION OF THOSE UP OF THOSE
DEMOGRAPHICS AND ON THE STE.
SHE HAS BEEN DESIGNATED A
HISPANIC SERVING INSTITUTION
REFLECT THE GREAT.
RESPONSIBILITY OF THAT THAT THE
COLLEGE HAS TO BE EDUCATIONAL
ATTAINMENT AND ECONOMIC WELL
BEING OF THE SURROUNDING
COMMUNITY. CORRELATION IS NOT
CAUSATION BUT WHAT I CAN TELL
YOU IS THAT. THE RECRUITMENTS
THAT IT RESULTED FROM WHEN THAT
LANGUAGE WAS INCLUDED IN OUR
JOB POSTINGS FOR FACULTY. OF
THE OF THE- FACULTY THAT WERE
HIRED THAT YEAR WE HAVE HEARD
SIXTEEN FACULTY 69% OF THE
HIRES WERE FEMALE AND 62% OF
THE HIRES WERE. PEOPLE OF COLOR.
PERSONS OF COLOR SO. WE'RE
DOING A LITTLE DIGGING INTO
THAT HE GAVE UP ALL OF OUR ALL
OF OUR RECRUITMENT HISTORICALLY
HAVE BEEN REVIEWED TO- THAT SO
THAT THE- THE COMPOSITION OF
THE HIRING COMMITTEE AND
SCREENING COMMITTEES- ARE
DIVERSE THAT THE POOL OF
APPLICANTS IS DIVERSE AND IF WE
DON'T GET A DIVERSE POOL GO
BACK BE AT HIGHS IN DIFFERENT
AREAS AND ALL THAT SO THOSE
THINGS DID NOT CHANGE WHAT THE
CHANGE WAS THE STATE. THIS
EQUITY MINDED STATEMENT AND SO
WHAT WE'RE. DID THAT STATEMENT
ENCOURAGE BECAUSE THE POOL WAS
THE SAME WE STILL HAVE A
DIVERSE POOL. WE WERE DID WE IN
BY THAT STATEMENT. PEOPLE OF
COLOR WHO KNEW THAT THIS
INSTITUTION RIVERSIDE CITY
COLLEGE WAS SERIOUS ABOUT ITS
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY SERIOUS
ABOUT THE EQUITY MINDED AND
CULTURALLY SENSITIVE PEDAGOGIES
THAT WE EXPECT ALL OF OUR
FACULTY TO HAVE. SO. A BIT OF A
WAYS TO GO WITH- WITH OUR
DIVERSIFICATION OF OUR FACULTY
WE ARE VERY POSITIVE AND WE'RE
VERY HEARTENED BY OUR MOST
RECENT EXPERIENCES- IN
INCLUDING- THAT EQUITY DID
LANGUAGE TO ALL OF OUR FACULTY
RECRUITMENT THE COLLEGE
PRESIDENT ALSO MEET WITH EVERY
FACULTY HIRING SCREEN COMMITTEE
TO EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE.
EQUITY MINDED. AND TEACHING WE
EXPECT TO HAVE HAPPEN AT THIS
COLLEGE- IN TERMS OF- OBSTACLES
AND CHALLENGES- PROVIDING
SUFFICIENT AND ENOUGH-
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT FOR
OUR FOR OUR EXISTING FACULTY-
HAS BEEN A CHALLENGE AS I'VE
SAID WE'VE SENT- MALL TO OUR TO
BE FOR THE URBAN EDUCATION AND
WE'RE NOW- WORKING ON THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- FOR THE
EQUITY INSTITUTE FROM SCOTT.
COLLEGE LOS HOTEL UP TO
ESTABLISH A AN EQUITY INSTEAD.
AB RIVERS CITY COLLEGE SO THAT
WE CAN- CONTINUE THAT COULD
WORK AND INSTITUTIONALIZE
THOSE- THOSE ATTITUDES AND
CHANGE THAT CULTURE- DATA TO
HELP ON THIS JOURNEY. WITH
REGARD TO ON BOARDING OUR
FACULTY IN MAINTAINING THE
FACULTY OF WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
FIRST YEAR COHORT EXPERIENCE IN
TERMS OF PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT FOR ALL OF OUR
INCOMING FACULTY. THE COLLEGE
IS ALSO CURRENTLY ENGAGED IN
DIALOGUE ABOUT HOW BEST TO
INTEGRATE- COLOR WHITE EQUITY
EXPECTATIONS INTO OUR
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES AND ALL
ALL OF WHAT WE DO. IN ADDITION
ON THE COLLEGE ESTABLISHED A
NEW A NEW COMMUNITY OF. FACULTY
ADMINISTRATORS AND- AND- UP
STAFF- STAFF EDUCATORS CALLED A
LOS THE ASSOCIATION OF LATIN X.
ADVOCATING FOR STUDENT SUCCESS
TO BUILD COMMUNITY AMONG OUR-
OUR LATIN X. STAFF AN
ADMINISTRATOR AND FACULTY
MEMBERS- SO ARE CHALLENGES THEN
AGAIN UP ARE MAKING SURE THAT
OUR PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
AND PARTING OF OUR FACULTY IS.
IS. SIX FOUR AND TO ONE AND
THEN. WITH ALL THIS WORK
OBVIOUSLY- FUNDING IS A
KNOWLEDGE AND IT'S SARAH IT'S.
DIFFICULT IN A B. B. THE- HIRED
THE LOWEST FUNDED. ENTITY AMONG
ALL THE EDUCATIONAL STRUCTURES
I'M SURE YOU'RE ALL OF HER THE
JUSTICES PARITY BETWEEN THE
FUNDING PER STUDENT FOR UC
VERSUS CAL STATE K. TWELVE AND
THEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND AT
THE BOTTOM. SO SOMEBODY HAS TO
BE ON THE BOTTOM BUT WE'RE
PRETTY SIGNIFICANTLY AT THE
BOTTOM AND SO ANYTHING THAT CAN
BE DONE TO A CITY THAT I THINK
ONLY HELP THE CAUSE. OF. EVEN
SEND OUR AND OUR FACULTY. THANK
YOU MR GARCIA ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS. NOT NECESSARY. YOU
KNOW IT IN THE INTEREST OF TIME.
ME THANK THIS PANEL VERY MUCH
AND WHAT I HEARD WAS THAT IT IS
UP TO THE LOCAL LEVEL. AND I
SALUTE EFFORT OF SAN JOSE CITY
IMPERIAL COLLEGE ARE RCC MY
COLLEGE HERE'S WHAT I HEARD.
THAT WE HAVE 60% LATINO
STUDENTS 20% LATINO FACULTY. SO
IN MY DISTRICT AT THIS COLLEGE.
I KNOW THERE'S LOTS OF WORK
STILL TO BE DONE THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR INPUT AND WILL GO ON TO
OUR LAST PANEL. SO FOR OUR LAST
PANEL. LIKE TO HEAR MORE ABOUT
AND REPRESENTED FACULTY BALANCE
HOW THEY BALANCE THEIR
CLASSROOM ROADS AND IN MANY
CASES THEIR DEFAULT ROLES OF
THE IN MANOR MENTORS TO UNDER
REPRESENTED STUDENTS BEING A
FORMER TEACHER AND A COLLEGE
TEACHER I CAN'T BELIEVE OUT
STUDENTS BUT UNFORTUNATELY THE
STUDENT FROM MARINO VALLEY.
THAT WE HAD INVITED. IS SICK
TODAY SO WITH THAT I WILL
WELCOME. THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE FROM RCC JOHN
STAND KISS AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE STUDENT SENATE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
A MEAN AND HELP ME WITH YOUR
LAST NAME. THANK YOU WELCOME.
WELCOME BOTH. ALL RIGHT. SO
ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU FOR TAKING
THE TIME TO INVITE THE STUDENTS
OFTENTIMES YOU CAN FEEL LIKE
WE'RE BEING LEFT OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION UNTIL IT'S TOO
LATE BUT TAKING THE TIME TO
DISCUSS THIS TYPE OF THING WITH
US AND SEE OUR PERSPECTIVES
REALLY DOES NOT. QUITE A BIT SO
THANK YOU FOR THAT. ALREADY ALL
THE PREVIOUS PRESENTERS I THINK
I'VE DONE A REALLY GOOD JOB OF
TALKING ABOUT THE VARIOUS WAYS
THIS SYSTEM- IS STRUGGLING TO
MEET. ITS DIVERSITY IDEALS. AND
I THINK THEY ALREADY DID THE
JOB OF TALKING ABOUT THE DATA
THAT GOES AROUND AND KIND OF
THEIR PERSPECTIVE SO I. WANT TO
TAKE THIS TIME TO TALK ABOUT
HOW IT AFFECTS ME AS A STUDENT.
SO ALREADY IT'S BEEN MENTIONED
THAT THE LEADERSHIP. THE
FACULTY AND ADMINISTRATORS OF
VARIOUS CALL SYSTEMS. DON'T
NOT. HAVE AS MUCH WORSE. WE'D
LIKE. BUT THE WAY THAT THIS
ACCESS STUDENTS IS IT SOME
AFFECTS OUR ABILITY TO TRUST.
SINCE. IT'S CRUCIAL SELECT SOME
CAMP IT'S OR EVEN MENTION ON
THE HOUSE SOMETIMES THIS CAN
LEAD TO A FEELING OF ISOLATION
WHEN YOU FEEL LIKE YOU'RE THE
ONLY MINORITY IN THE SITUATION
AS A STUDENT THAT'S ALSO FILLED
WITH AMPLIFIED ALREADY IS A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT CAN
FEEL ISOLATED IF YOU GO TO A
HIGH SCHOOL YOU'RE FORCED TO
INTERACT WITH INSPIRED. CLASSES
IF YOU GO TO YOU SEE CSU YOU'RE
FORCED. CONNECTIONS FACULTY ARE
ONE OF THE EASIEST WAYS TO SEE
WHAT'S HAPPENING ON CAMPUS AND
HAVING FACULTY WERE IT AS
DIVERSE AS THE POPULATION IS.
ALLOWS US TO SEE WHAT CAN BE
DONE ESPECIALLY IN CAR TAX OUT
OF TO US- I CAN'T. TELL YOU HOW
MANY TIMES I'VE SEEN SOMEBODY
COME UP TO ME AND TALK ABOUT
HOW THIS ONE PERFECT. TOUGHEST
DOCTOR HE WAS THE INTEREST IN
BUT NOW AFTER THE TAUGHT. ME
THAT WAS RELEVANT TO WHAT THEIR
EXPERIENCES ARE THEY FELT LIKE
THEY HAD MONEY OR BY AN AND
MUCH MORE BELIEF I BELIEVE IT
WAS THE PRESENT. IMAGINE THAT
AS THE WORLD. I REALLY THOUGHT
WAS A GREAT WAY OF PUTTING IT.
THE IMPACT ON SUCCESS MAJORS IN
GRADES HAS ALREADY BEEN
ELABORATED ON. BUT MORE
HOLISTICALLY ALSO AFFECTS OUR
ABILITY TO SIX OUR ABILITY FEEL
CONFIDENT AS LEADERS THESE
YEARS ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE
COMING OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL WHERE
YOU'RE NONTRADITIONAL STUDENT
CAN BE. YOU CAN SEE YOUR
SUCCESSFUL LATER PATHWAYS AND-
SO- GAINING THE CONFIDENCE IN
FUELING YOU HAVE AN ACTUAL
IMPACT THE WAY THAT STUDENTS DO
WHEN THEY HAVE A MORE DIVERSE-
FOR FORTY WHO WELCOMES THE MEN
ISRAEL CRUCIAL- WITH REGARDS TO
SOLUTIONS I THINK A LOT HAVE
BEEN MENTIONED. I THINK ALIVE
BEEN MENTIONED ALREADY. THE
ONES THAT STUCK OUT TO ME ARE
OBVIOUSLY INCREASING THE AMOUNT
OF DIVERSE FACULTY IT'S NOT THE
EASIEST SOLUTION BUT I DO THINK
IT'S SIMPLE THIS AND I THINK AS
A STUDENT THAT'S THE ONE
THEY'LL HAVE THE MOST DIRECT
AFFECT MY ABILITY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL I THINK SOMETHING
ELSE I SHOULD BE MANY. ACCOUNTS
LORS COACHES WHOEVER HAS OF
OUTWARD SING ROLE THAT DIRECTOR.
NOT JUST INCREASING THE AMOUNT
OF DIVERSITY BUT ALSO
INCREASING THE AMOUNT OF MAYBE.
CULTURAL SENSITIVITY TRAINING
STUFF LIKE THAT THOSE MISSION
IS ALSO CRUCIAL SO THAT THE
UNDERSTAND MAYBE THE
BACKGROUNDS AND EXPERIENCES
THAT WE ALL LIVE IN. ANOTHER
THING THAT I THOUGHT I'D
FINALLY AND WITH IS MAYBE
THEY'LL GIVE ME ONCE FOR
EXAMPLE- I'M A NORTH AFRICAN.
ART I'M NORTH UP THE CENTER SO
SINCE THE ARAB. NO WE'RE REALLY
IN THIS CONVERSATION DOES IT
SEEM LIKE I MAYBE FIT IN THIS
CONTEXT RIGHT. SOMETIMES WE
TAKE LONG BEEN ASIAN AS THIS
ONE BIG GROUP. SOUTH ASIAN IN
EAST ASIA. RIGHT DIFFERENT. IS
COMING UP IN THE SYSTEM RIGHT
THIS BUDGET. ARM WITH THE WAY
THINGS ARE SET UP. MORE GETTING
MORE CORRECT WITH. A CAMBODIAN
ORAL SURGEON STUDENT IS IN ONE.
EXPERIENCES CHINA. ALREADY THE
WERE. WONDERFUL IT'S READ. ALL
THESE. LINES COMING TOGETHER TO
SEE HOW THEY CAN SOLVE SUCH A
VITAL ISSUE. BUT MORE
GRANULARITY MORE NEW WANTS AND
MORE THE SAME WHICH IS BRING
TOGETHER MEETING OF THE MINDS
TO DISCUSS THESE ISSUES THANK
YOU. YOU. IT IS AFTER GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEDINA ASSEMBLY
PERSON GARCIA- MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC UNLESS STAFF I AM JOHN.
RESIDENTS OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND I ROLE I
AM TO REPRESENT ALL THE FACULTY
STONE. IN ACADEMIC AND
PROFESSIONAL MANNER THE DON'T
ASK ME ABOUT HOW MUCH PEOPLE
GET PAID. OKAY. YOU'VE HEARD A
LOT TODAY ALREADY AND I'VE BEEN
THROUGH CROSS OUT THINGS ON MY
NOW SO AS NOT TO MENTION. SO I
HOPE THAT I CAN PROVIDE JUST A
LITTLE BIT MORE TAXED FOR I
KNOW I AM STANDING BETWEEN YOU
AND LUNCH SEC. I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT THE ACCURATE AND IT
HAS. HAS EXPRESSED ITS CONCERN
AND DESIRE TO LEAD
CONVERSATIONS AROUND THE
DIVERSIFICATION OF OUR RANKS
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY SIX WHEN
WE EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP TWO OH
NINE. A AND HOW THAT WOULD THAT
AFFECT. OUR ABILITY TO SERVE
OUR STUDENTS- I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT IN TWO THOUSAND TWO
WE WERE PART OF THE TASK FORCE
THAT FAILED. WITH THE FIRST
OFFICE IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
WE PARTNERED WITH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE ABOUT
IMPLEMENTING THE NEW E.
GUIDELINES AND PROVIDING
NATIONAL DEVELOPMENT PROCESS
STATE. AS A BASELINE. THE WE
NEED WASN'T. THIS WAS A STAFF.
ON THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND IT
APPEARED IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN OUT WE APPROACH THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN THE
SUMMER. I DON'T KNOW IF YOU HOW
YOU RECALL THE SPRING OF TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN BUT IT WAS
RATHER DIFFICULT TIME FOR THOSE
OF US WITHIN THE SYSTEM. AND
ASKED THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
TO WORK WITH US AND MAKE THIS A
PRIORITY THAT MY EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE. WHO ON YOUR HAND OUT
THIS IS US SO THIS IS. THIS IS
WHO WE ARE. IMPLEMENTED SOME
GOALS WHAT WE WISH TO WORK ON-
AND PROVIDE LEADERSHIP FOR THE
SYSTEM FOR AND OUR NUMBER ONE
GOAL WAS THE DIVERSIFICATION OF
OUR RANKS AND WE SAID THIS
WOULD NEED TO BE A GOAL FOR AT
LEAST FIVE YEARS IF WHAT
HAPPENED. BECAUSE WE TALK. STEM
CULTURE CHANGE. WAS THAT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT EVERY SYSTEM
REFLECTS THE INHERENT BIAS OF
THE TIME OF CONSTRUCTION
INCLUDING OURS. INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND EACH OF OUR DISTRICTS. AND
THAT SYSTEMS ARE DESIGNED TO
RESIST CHANGE IF LEFT ON THEIR
OWN. AND WE ALSO BELIEVE IN THE
CAPACITY OF EVERYONE TO LEARN
AND GROW INCLUDING OURSELVES
AND THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CHANGE THE SYSTEM IN WHICH WE
WORK. THE FACULTY THAT I SPEAK
TO OUR CALL TO TEACHER. THEY
FEEL A DESIRE TO GIVE BACK TO
THEIR COMMUNITIES TO HELP
PEOPLE ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS.
ALL OF US WANT TO DO THAT TO
THE BEST OF OUR ABILITY AND
WHEN WE GET TOGETHER AND TALK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN DO THAT. IT
USUALLY A FUNCTION OF. HOW CAN
WE DO. HOW CAN WE EMPOWER
PEOPLE TO MAKE CHANGES. SOME OF
THE WORK I'M- YOU HEARD FROM-
DOCTOR DAISY GONZALEZ- EARLIER
THAT- WE ARE PARTNERED WITH HER
OFFICE TO A CO CHAIRED THE TASK
FORCE AND THE LIST OF
RECOMMENDATIONS- THAT WE WISH
TO IMPLEMENT. WE WENT TO THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS MEETING AND
MY EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE
AUTHORIZED ME TO SEE THIS. THIS
IS OUR NUMBER ONE PRIORITY IN
THE BUDGET THIS IS THAT THIS IS
WHAT WE NEED TO DO. OVER THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT YOU
HEARD FROM ALL THE PREVIOUS
SPEAKERS NEEDS TO HAPPEN IN A
CONSISTENT WAY. HI ONCE AND
DONE BUT OVER TIME TO IMPLEMENT
A CULTURE CHANGE THE WORK THAT
THE SENATE HAS SAID THAT IT
NEEDS TO LEAD AND HAS ASKED OUR
SYSTEM PARTNERS TO INVITED THEM
TO COME IN AND APPOINT PEOPLE
AND HELP US TO IT- INCLUDE. EVE
OUT. SECOND AMONG QUALIFICATION
THAT WE JUST ABOUT SUCH THAT
ITS VALUE IS EQUAL TO DISTANCE
DISCIPLINE SPECIFIC
QUALIFICATIONS THERE ARE TWO
MINIMUM QUALIFICATIONS FOR
FACULTY. YOU SHOULD MEET BOTH.
I'M TO TEACH IN THE SYSTEM AND
ONE SHOULD NOT BE MORE VALUABLE
THAN THE OTHER. IS TO CREATE
WITH OUR SYSTEM PARTNERS AT
MODEL HIRING AN APPOINTMENT
PROCESSES- AS TOOLS THE
COLLEGES CAN USE- AND THESE ARE
ALL. IN THE HUNDRED.
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT DOCTOR
GONZALEZ MENTIONED EARLIER.
ALSO TO DEVELOP TOOLS TO ENGAGE
COLLEGES AND SYSTEMIC CHANGE
DIALOGUE. THIS IS- OUR LOCAL
ACADEMIC SENATE PRESIDENTS COME
FROM ALL KINDS OF DISCIPLINES
AND MAY NOT BE AS PROFICIENT
ABOUT THAT THE DELEGATES THAT
THEY SEND THEIR SENATE
PRESIDENT'S THEY COME TO OUR
PLENARY SESSION HAVE TOLD US
THIS. TO THEM AND THEY WANT TO
DO THAT. BUT THE CONTROLS TO
HELP THAT. LIKE THEY CAN
FACILITATE A DIALOGUE BUT THEY
NEED SOME STRUCTURE AROUND THAT
SO THE STATE WIDE ACADEMICS AND
IT IS ATTEMPTING TO BUILD
THOSE. FOR THEM AND TO WORK
WITH THAT THE FIRST OFFICE TO
EVALUATE AND REVISE OUR E. OF
STANDARDS. THAT IN THE TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN SIXTEEN AND-
THEN THE MOTHER MEASURE WE ASK
COLLEGES TO DO. WE KNEW THAT AS
A BASELINE. EVERYONE HAS THE
BASELINE THAT MEANS IT'S TIME
TO MOVE TO THE NEXT STOP. I IN
OUR PROGRESS. SOME OF THE WORK
THAT WE HAVE ALSO DONE THAT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO
HEAR IS A SELF EXAMINATION OF
OUR OWN GOVERNANCE PROCESSES AS
THE- BASE OF FACULTY AND
ACADEMIC AND PROFESSIONAL
MATTERS. IF YOU ALL HAVE THIS
CHART HERE IT MAY NOT SEEM
SUPER IMPRESSIVE TO YOU I BUT
WE HAVE MADE AN INTENTIONAL
EFFORT TO REACH OUT TO
DIFFERENT GROUPS OF FACULTY AND
INVITE THEM INTO THE GOVERNANCE
DIALOGUE. THAT WE'VE HEARD
FROM- DOCTOR FAVIO GONZALEZ
THAT THAT SOMETIMES THAT
INVITATION IS LACKING OR
PERCEIVED AS NOT TO ME AND SO
WE HAVE MADE AN INTENTIONAL
EFFORT TO PARTNER WITH OTHER
GROUPS WHERE WE- GROUPS OF
FACULTY ARE MORE DIVERSE
ALREADY IN OUR SYSTEM. AND ASK
THEM TO PARTICIPATE. ALL OF
THEM WE NEED ALL THE VOICE. TO
SERVE ALL THE STUDENTS. WE TAKE
A SNAPSHOT OF THE MIDDLE OF
AUGUST WHICH IS WHEN WE
FINALIZE OUR STANDING
COMMITTEES OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE EVENTUALLY WE HAVE TO
APPOINT A THOUSAND PEOPLE. BUT
BUT WE'VE BEEN TAKING A
SNAPSHOT OF THE STANDING
COMMITTEES AND STANDING
APPOINTMENTS. THIS NUMBER OF
THE TOTAL APPLICANT POOL IN THE
MIDDLE OF AUGUST I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU KNOW IT IF YOU RESET
EVERY ACADEMIC YEAR IT'LL OF
AUGUST IS NOT AN OPPORTUNE
TIME. COLLECTED MATCH IS
USUALLY AROUND A HUNDRED BUT
THIS PAST YEAR WE HAD TWO
HUNDRED FORTY FOUR. I WOULD
HOPE AS A RESULT OF OUR DIRECT-
ASKING PEOPLE TO DISSIPATE AND
YOU LOOK AT WHAT THE APPLICANT
POOL VERSUS THE PERCENTAGE UP
TO IT. LIKE IS IT PERFECT. IS
IT- AND IMPROVEMENTS YES I
THINK IT IS. WHEN WE CONTINUE
TO EVALUATE AND MONITOR OUR OWN
PROCESSES AS AN EXAMPLE TO
LOCAL SENATE'S OF WHAT THEY
CAN'T. AROUND THAT. I WAS ASKED
TO LEAVE LOTS AND LOTS OF TIME
FOR QUESTIONS. SO I THINK I'LL
STOP. THANK YOU. I WOULD SAY.
THAT I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
WORK OF THE ACADEMIC SENATE THE
MEETINGS THAT WE'VE HAD- IN
SACRAMENTO- OVER THE YEARS I'VE
I THINK MORE THAN ONCE A YEAR
AND I KNOW FROM THOSE MEETINGS
THAT WE'VE HAD IN SACRAMENTO
THAT. FACULTY THIS. ACADEMIC A
PRIORITY BECAUSE I'VE SEEN THAT
IN THE IN THE MEMBERSHIP OF THE
FOLKS WHEN YOU COME TO VISIT
WITH ME. AND I'VE I'VE HEARD.
AND I APPLAUD THE IMPROVEMENT
IN THE DIVERSITY OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE ITSELF. USING
THE COLLEGE OPPORTUNITIES
NUMBERS IN YOUR YOUR OWN NUMBER.
I'M GLAD YOU REALIZE THAT YOU
HAVE ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT
WITHIN THE ACADEMIC COURSE
STUFF AND THAT YOU ARE MAKING
IT PROVED MEN'S IS A KNOWLEDGE.
AND I AND I REALLY DO THINK
THAT IS A STEP FORWARD SO
YOU'RE YOU'RE YOU'RE LOOKING AT
A GROUP OF FACULTY WHO ALREADY
NOT VERY DIVERSE AND THEN
ASKING THEM TO DO MORE. AND WE
KNOW THAT IF CAUGHT. ON AT
EVERY LEVEL. TAXED HIGHER IN
THE SENSE THAT THEY HAVE MORE
RESPONSIBILITIES AND ACT AS
MENTORS TO STUDENTS AND THEN
YOU'RE ASKING THEM TO DO MORE
SO I UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGE
FOR THE ACADEMIC SENATE BUT I'M
GLAD YOU'RE MOVING IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION AND I THINK THAT'LL
HELP. RIGHT AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
FIVE THANK YOU INTO IT I THINK
MY QUESTION THIS ONLINE WITH.
YOU WERE JUST TALKING ABOUT WE
THINK A POPULAR SAYS THAT
YOU'RE ASKING. IN A BATTLE TO.
OKAY. AND WE ARE ASKING THEM TO
DO MORE. ARE YOU WHERE THIS
TAKE TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
SUPPORTED AND THAT EMPOWERED
WAS THERE TO BILL LIKE TO
ACTUALLY BE HEARD OR TAKING
LEADERSHIP ROLES IS A LOT OF
I'VE BEEN INVITED. TO TAKE OFF
THE BOX WITHIN THE TO SUNSET
THAT. IN NINETEEN IS THAT IS SO
ARE YOU HAVING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE NEXT
STEP. THAT IS NOT JUST AN
INVITATION BUT IT'S AN
EMPOWERMENT AND THEN A SUPPORT
FOR. US SEC I EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE WHOSE PICTURED ON THE
FRONT THERE MIGHT- BE GLAD AND
LEAVING SAN FROM THIS ROLE- BUT
I HAVE ASKED THEM TO CO TWO
ORIENTATION. OF FOR THREE DAYS
IN JUNE DAY IN JULY AND EXTRA
TWO DAYS IN AUGUST EVERY YEAR
WHERE WE TALK ABOUT. THE TRADE
PLAZA BIAS TRAINING WHAT IS
SEEN TO BE INCLUSIVE OF ALL
VOICES WHEN YOU WERE LEADING
THESE COMMITTEES. HOW DO YOU-
IMPROVE THE PARTICIPATION OF
YOUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
REALLY CAT THE VIEW POINT OF
THAT THIS IS BEN. SO I'M ASKING
ALL OF MY EXECUTIVE EIGHTY TO
WORK WHEN THEY'RE PROBABLY NOT
ON CONTRACT. ALL SUMMER TO DO
THIS AND THEY DO IT BECAUSE WE
VALUE. AND THIS IS IN PART.
THANK YOU WELL THANK YOU TO
THIS PANEL AND WE ARE NOT GOING
TO MOVE FORWARD TO- PUBLIC
COMMENTS I UNDERSTAND. THAT WE
HAVE A ROVING MICROPHONE. OF
FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS THE BEFORE
WE START PUBLIC EVENTS I WANT
EGGNOG. ONE THING IN. AND I
JUST SEE HERE. I WAS A LONG
TIME HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER HERE
AT RIVERSIDE A HIGH SCHOOL. AND
ONE EXPERIENCES HERE AT
RIVERSIDE COMMUNITY COLLEGE THE
CHANGE MY TEACHING STYLE CHANGE
THE WAY I TAUGHT. WITH THE
MEETING A PROFESSOR HERE FROM
RCC WHO WAS PROFESSOR OF THE
YEAR. IN THE UNITED STATES NOW
PROFESSOR I SEE SITTING HERE IS
DOCTOR CLARENCE ROMERO SO WENIG
KNOWLEDGE DOCTOR ROMERO HE
TAUGHT ME TO THINK OUTSIDE THE
BOX AND HOW I INTERACTED WITH
MY STUDENTS I SAW A VIDEO AND I
DON'T KNOW WHO DID IT BUT I SAW
TWO DIFFERENT STYLES OF
TEACHING AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE
ONE WAS A PROFESSOR WHO TURNED
HIS BACK ON THE STUDENTS I
FORGET WHAT'S UP HE WAS
TEACHING. AND SAID. YOU KNOW
THE STUDENTS WILL BE IT WHERE
THEY WILL GET IT. YEAH IT MAY
HAVE BEEN MATH OF. THE WOMAN
RAISED IT MAY BEEN MATH AND
THEY'LL EITHER GET IT OR NOT
GET IT BUT FROM DOCTOR ROMERO I
LEARNED THE IMPORTANCE OF
INTERACTION WITH STUDENTS. I A-
BIRD ALSO FROM A DOCTOR FAVIO
GONZALEZ THE CHANGE DOESN'T
HAPPEN SOUTH CHANGE TAKES
PEOPLE WORKING FOR CHANGE. DR
ROMERO IS ONE OF THOSE KINDS OF
PEOPLE WHO PUSHES AND PUSHES
FOR CHANGE I THINK THAT WOULD
TAKE SO I'M VERY HAPPY AND
WANTED KNOWLEDGE DOCTOR AMERICA
HERE. AND WITH THAT. WE ARE
GOING TO GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AND WE WILL IF WE HAVE ANY.
HAVE A MICROPHONE HERE AND WE
WILL LIMIT. THE TIME TO TWO
MINUTES REPUBLICANS. DR AMERICA.
THANK YOU JOSE MY FRANKLY I WAS
VERY SADDENED SHARED A TEARFUL
YOU QUIT TEACHING. I WAS VERY
SAD WHEN YOU LEFT ARE BOARD
WE'VE SECOND INCOMES BOARD. BUT
I'M SO GLAD YOU ARE HERE TODAY.
IF I HAVE A TEARS ONLY BECAUSE-
WE ARE HERE. IT IS A DISMAL
FAILURE CALLED RCC. I CAME HERE
TO THROW THE GAUNTLET I MAY NOT
HAVE A JOB TOMORROW. THE
MACHINE I HAVE NOT DONE ENOUGH.
20% THAT'S DISGUSTING. MY DAD
CAME HERE IS A WORLD WAR TWO
VETERAN. TOLD YOU CANNOT BUY
YOUR BECAUSE IT'S QUITE. YEAH
MY DAD CRY. I NEVER THOUGHT I
WOULD WRITE BECAUSE WE WERE IN
A ROOM RIVERSIDE UNIFIED SCHOOL
SEGREGATED SCHOOL DISTRICT. WE
ARE FROGS WE LEARNED ANYTHING.
I APPRECIATE ARMENIAN THE WAY
HE SPOKE AND ELOQUENT SPEAKER
CLEAR CONCISE EXPLICIT I WISH I
COULD SPEAK THAT WELL. BUT I'M
HERE TO CHALLENGE RCC. SEVENTY
FIVE YEARS OF TIME IT DOESN'T
TAKE SEVENTY FIVE YEARS TO MAKE
A CHANGE IF I'M NOT HERE I
ACCEPT MY FATE. BUT I'M ASHAMED
HAVE NOT DONE ENOUGH I MISS THE
DAYS WHEN I TOOK STUDENTS TO
YOUR CLIENTS AND YOU WERE OPEN
TO THAT. I MISS THOSE DAYS WHEN
WE HAD WHEN WE HAVE. LATINO
EDUCATORS OF TOMORROW. WE HAVE
TOOL FOR TIME AJ TEACHERS HERE
ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE WE
DON'T HAVE ONE SINGLE
EDUCATIONAL FULBRIGHT TEACHER
HERE TO TEACHERS TO BE TEACHERS
WE DON'T HAVE THAT ARE C. C. I
TOLD THE DOC LET. I OFFER THE
CHALLENGE AND I OFFER MYSELF AS
A. LEVINE YOUR FRONT RCC AS
WELL I WAS ASHAMED TO COME HERE
I DID NOT COME HERE BUT I DID
AND I FROM. MY TWO MINUTES ARE
UP. BUT FROM MY DAD AND HIS
TEARS I BRING YOU A MESSAGE.
TWENTY FOUR. IT'S DISGUSTING
THE DISMAL FAILURE WE DON'T
HAVE WORK TO DO ALL. WE HAVE
FAILED. AND IF WE DON'T DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT TODAY I
DON'T ME TOMORROW I DON'T MEAN
BOARDS IS STANDARD OPERATIONAL
PROCEDURES I DON'T THINK THAT
AT ALL. VOLUNTEERED COMMITTEE
ON ANY LOCAL COMMITTEE THAT'LL
MAKE THIS CHANGE TOMORROW NOT
WAS STANDARD OPERATIONAL
PROCEDURES BUT RATHER WITH
ACTION WITH THE TERMINATION WAS
LEADERSHIP THAT'S WHY I CAME
HERE TODAY AND I DID CANCEL
SOME OF MY CLASSES ARE YOU
CONDUCT MY PAY FOR THAT. NOT
TAKE IT BUT I CAN'T. BECAUSE I
AM ASHAMED OF RCC AND I AM NOT
A BENEFICIARY OF VICTIM AND I
AM A FULL TIME TENURED
PROFESSOR IN MAYES NOTHING TO
ME FOR ME PHD MAYES PROFOUND
HIM RIGHT- THIS ORDER AND
NOTHING ELSE I LIKE WHAT YOU
SAID ABOUT A MASTERS. SEARCH
WE'RE HERE TO DO BASIC
EDUCATIONAL SKILLS SO. PROGRESS
THIS IS ABOUT THE STUDENT NOT
ABOUT US IT'S ABOUT THE STORY
AND THEY MUST KNOW THAT THEY
COULD SEE THEIR PEOPLE AND I'M
GOING TO USE MY WORDS FROM
NELSON MANDELA EDUCATIONAL
APARTHEID WHEN THE PEOPLE THAT
TEACHERS DO NOT REPRESENT YOU
WITH ALL OF COLOR ARE YOU I'VE
BEEN SAYING THIS FOR YEARS WAS
THERE. THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
THANK YOU FOR LETTING ME SPEAK
AND I APPROACH EVERYTHING YOU
IN THE COMMITTEE WITH BOND AND
I KNOW MOST OF YOU HAVE BEEN ON
YOUR CELL PHONES. I KNOW.
BECAUSE I AS A TEACHER LOOK FOR
THAT PAGE YOU. THE PURPOSE ROOM
A ROOM OKAY WITH YOUR- WHAT'S
THE UNIVERSITY BUT I IS THE
THAT IN THE AUDIENCE I SAW TOO
MANY PEOPLE ON THIS LIST AND I
APOLOGIZE TO YOU YOU HAVE THE
RIGHT TO BE ON YOUR CELL PHONE.
I DON'T EVEN. A CELL PHONE I
DON'T WANT THE TEMPTATION.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE IF I'M
NOT HERE TOMORROW. BY BUT I
WILL BE A MODEL I WAS RAISED
HERE. WILL STAY HERE I WILL DIE
HERE. AND WHEN IT COMES TO
TEACHING YOU CAN CARRY ME OUT
OF MY CLASSROOM IN A COFFIN OR
FIRE ME TOMORROW. WORKS FOR ME
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR TWO. OF
YOU THANK YOU DOCTOR AMERICA.
ANY OTHER. COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC. NOT SEEN ANY. I WILL
USE DOCTOR ROMERO'S REMARKS AS
AS PART OF MY CLOSING. IT'S
BEEN A LENGTHY RECESSION. THE
SUBJECT IS NOT NEW THE SUBJECT
MATTER SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
BEEN AS DOCTOR REMEMBER REMINDS
IS WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT FOR
PROBABLY OVER FIFTY YEARS. IT'S
COMPLICATED. IN THE SENSE THAT
THERE ARE A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
DIFFERENT COLLEGES AND WE DEAL
WITH FACULTY AND SENATE.
MINISTRATIONS BUT AGAIN.
REMEMBER IN BACK TO THE
PROFESSOR FROM BERKELEY WHO
SAID. THE WOULD DO IT TWO ONE
TWO WE DON'T DO IT WHEN WE
DON'T WANT TO. I HOPE. THAT ALL
THE DATA AND EVERYTHING ELSE
THAT WE'VE HEARD HERE TODAY
FROM STUDENTS THE IMPORTANCE OF
DIVERSE FACULTY. TO STUDENTS
THE DIFFERENCE THAT MAKES IN
THEIR LIVES. THE WE'VE HEARD
NOT ONLY AT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BUT WITHIN THE YOU SEE THE
DIFFERENCE THE DIVERSE FACULTY
MAKES. IN STUDENTS LIVES. YOU
SEE THAT YOU SEE THAT ON A
DAILY BASIS. WE MUST DO BETTER.
WE MUST DO BETTER WE MUST DO
BETTER SOON WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK TOGETHER I THANK YOU ALL
FOR COMING. MR SEAT. WHEN I
REPEAT OF DR. WITH RUMORS
COMMENTS BUT JUST TEACHING SO I
THINK THAT SIMPLY FORGET THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE REGULAR BASIS
AND BECAUSE WE HAVE A SERVICE
THE CITY WE KNOW HOW TO TEACH
WHERE WE HAVE A PIZZA THIS I
MEAN ON TV AND A SEVEN TO TALK
ABOUT THE I FELT THAT IT WAS
THE REVERSE OFTENTIMES AND- AS
MY RIGHT AWAY SAID IT SOUNDS
LIKE A MATH PROFESSOR TALKING.
AVAILABLE TOO QUICK TO PUT
BLAME ON SOMEONE ELSE SOMETIMES
A BUT I DO THINK WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON THE TEACHER TO TEACHER
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
LOOK AT IT ON THE PRIVACY MADE
BUT I DO THINK. WE NEED TO HAVE
THAT THAT'S A VERY TENSE
BECAUSE THAT IS HOW. TO AS- AN
ON. ALL FOR BEING HERE I THANK
YOU FOR STAYING WITH THIS. THIS
WHOLE TIME. I THANK THE A THE-
A COLLEGE FACULTY. WHO DAY IN
AND DAY OUT. DO THE WORK-
INTERACT WITH THEIR STUDENTS I
THANK THE STUDENTS FOR THEIR
VOICES. AND THAT ONE OF MAKE
SURE THAT THIS TO THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
CONTINUE. TO HAVE THEIR VOICES
HEARD. I THANK THE
ADMINISTRATORS WHO. I SEE IN
THE COMMUNITY. I SEE IN THE
COMMUNITY. AT AT ALL THE
DIFFERENT GROUPS I THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL AND WE WILL BE A
JERK. THANK YOU